tonight Tucker Carlson returned to
Twitter with a new show and in his show
he talked about what's going on in
Ukraine with these this uh this Dam that
exploded and who did it was it Ukraine
was it Russia now of course Western
media saying Russia did it Russia is
saying Ukraine did it and then there are
elements of the of the media in the
United States that are questioning who
did it saying we don't know for sure I
mean a lot of the corporate press
actually is saying both sides are
accusing each other but there are a lot
of people online who are saying it makes
more sense that it was Ukraine trying to
do it not Russia but typically the
honest it's fog of War we don't know in
response to this Tucker is getting a
warm welcome from the corporate press
who are ragging on him calling calling
him a conspiracy theorist and uh I think
generally they're just freaking out
because the fact that he was able to
take his show to Twitter and get a
substantial amount of audience of market
share shows they are completely
irrelevant and this is only making it
worse for them it was bad enough that we
were competing directly and we do
compete directly with these cable
networks but but now you can just do
your show anywhere podcast Twitter VOD
on demand whatever you want to do we got
other news we gotta talk about
actor Elliot page
yes the the horrifying Jesse Smollett
3.0 story where Ellie page claims that
in the gay neighborhood West Hollywood
of Los Angeles that uh on the same
telling the story on the same day that
Ellie Page's book is coming out claimed
that a man walked up and verbatim said
that they would gay bash Elliot page and
this is why they need a gun and Jesse
Smollett is probably you know rolling
his eyes being been there done that
because nobody believes this story so
we're gonna we're gonna get into that
and as well have a bunch of as well as a
bunch of other stories cities are
collapsing and we've got a variety of
stories in this regard the Hilton in San
Francisco is surrendering its property I
believe the entire property to its to
its uh creditors it's just basically
saying you can have it we're done we're
out because SF has collapsed so much and
get this in Seattle
people have been trying to steal fire
trucks that's how bad it's getting so
sounds like fun we'll get into that
stuff before we do my friends head over
to castbrew.com and purchase coffee cast
brew coffee is our coffee company we're
sponsoring ourselves because we want to
build companies that compete with these
woke awful corporations and there's a
there's a market opportunity there you
can choose to give your money to
companies that hate you or you can give
your money to companies that support you
agree with your values and want to do
more so when you buy cast brew coffee
that money is going towards setting up
our coffee shops and just generally
expanding the company and helping us do
more so that we can create a parallel
economy and compete with ESG and will
corporations but don't forget to also go
to timcast.com click that join us button
to become a member as a member you'll
get access to uncensored members only
shows Monday through Thursday at 10 pm
but they also are archived forever you
can go watch any of the old episodes and
if you sign up at the 25 per month level
or you're a member for at least six
months you can actually call into the
show and talk to us and our guests so
smash smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
this and a whole lot more is just pearly
things
hello thank you who are you my name is
Pearl I run the show just pearly things
I'm on my channel and I host live shows
with women
um three times a week when I'm in London
and yeah we usually debate on like
random things right on yeah there's a
there's a story right now that we'll
talk about in the New York Post that
says there's a trend in podcasting to
make fun of dumb women and they're
highlighting specifically the whatever
podcast yeah yeah that's that's my
favorite hobby but I but I think we'll
get into this I just think
it's wrong because whatever podcast has
has a bunch of smart women on the show
as well it's not like it's just let's go
find dumb women and make fun of them
it's he he brings on they bring on
different kinds of women who disagree
disagree and then people on the internet
make fun of them well and it's also like
when there's a show where men get
roasted there's no there's no article
saying oh we feel bad for the dumb men
yeah right there where where's no one
feels bad for for dumb men it's a
problem for us that's right very hard
yeah look my life isn't easy I'll say
that the fact that I've accomplished
what I am yeah it's like remarkable so
anyway it makes me more impressive
actually thanks for hanging out for all
it should be fun we'll talk about a lot
of stuff I'm sure you'll have a lot of
thoughts on the Ukraine war and Russia
and foreign policy oh yeah I know so
much I know so much and we got shame is
hanging out my name is Seamus Coughlin
uh I make cartoons for a living
um and I make fun of people on the
Internet it's quite fun I've also made
fun of the whatever podcast you guys
might want to check that cartoon out it
was a lot of fun uh Freedom tune go over
there check it out we just dropped it to
Bunker's video today we're gonna drop
another cartoon Thursday
I also run a podcast called shamer on
Rumble I had an incredible interview
today with uh Jimmy Aiken he is just in
encyclopedia and we were talking about
conspiracy theories so I think you guys
would really enjoy that if you want to
check that out tonight I'm back
and I'm not saying
but it's aliens that did not visit us
they're trying to manipulate people
there's their seating tear they're
trying to see who's who's gonna buy it
who's gonna buy the next big thing let's
give them this one let's give them that
alien thing or aliens are real or aliens
are real and they have visited Earth and
there are alien spacecraft on Earth as
we speak we we actually talked about
that on the podcast I just did with
Jimmy Acres like I said the guy's an
encyclopedia man shamer shamer check it
out on my right we have Serge du preya
yes I am surge.com and I'm excited for
today it's uh good to have you back in
as always yeah and uh yeah good to meet
you Pearl pleasure be fun let's get
started let's jump into this uh the
first story and this was the big news
that's trending on Twitter right now
Tucker goes full conspiracy theorist on
Twitter I love this today the mail they
are not too happy with Tucker's position
on the war in Ukraine because Daily Mail
of course is super pro Ukraine but they
say x Fox host debuts his new show and
RAM
about the West's unwavering support for
Ukraine questions why UFO whistleblower
is not dominating the news and says
Americans live in ignorance
um okay so what was he wrong about yes
the West is just insanely obsessed with
Ukraine and there's tons of Lies I like
how uh there's a meme going on right now
because of this uh this Dam that got
blown up they were like in three months
they're gonna come back and be like oh
yeah we knew it the whole time right The
Washington Post reported that apparently
we knew about the the attempts to
sabotage the Nordstrom pipeline well in
advance and so now when it comes to
blowing up this Dam in in uh in Ukraine
they're claiming Russia did it surprise
surprise it'll probably be in three
months they'll say actually it was
Ukraine who did it but anyway look I'm
not I'm not trying to ignite that whole
conversation deep foreign policy stuff
we can get into in a second the big
story is just that Tucker Carlson has
returned he cannot be stopped episode
one he just posted it's got 148 000
likes and the big picture here is the
media is officially dead the corporate
media it's over man I longed for this
day so I remember this at 6 PM I just
want to talk if you can move I'm
streaming at 6 PM so I'd appreciate it
if you like slid over Tucker Carlson
because we did okay today but I think if
he keeps this up he might steal our
audience and Tucker Carlson posted his
first episode the first episode of his
show on June 6th at 6 pm
oh I mean I would love to conspiracy
theorize with you all but I did do an
episode today on June 6th at 6 P at 6
p.m I can't I didn't mean to really it
wasn't on purpose well it never is but
it happened yeah maybe you're right the
road it wasn't my first episode it
wasn't my first episode though I think
people are gonna need to evolve to start
being able to listen to two
conversations at once because there's
too many shows at six o'clock you just
gotta put two on it maybe two and then
three and then four just pick the show
that you like and you watch the show
that you like and if you guys all make
videos here you should put on videos of
yourself to listen to yourself and then
put on multiple videos of yourself at
the same time it's like heightened
evolution
how many views does that have oh let's
find out I am looking right now so it's
been up for two hours and it has nine
million wow oh my gosh that has more
views I just want you to know this is so
popular he is popular and he should be
my dad loves him I don't actually know
much about Tucker Carlson he used to be
like deep State chill without realizing
like he was in The Matrix he wore a bow
tie and just did talking points for the
military industrial complex and then he
had this interview with Jon Stewart
where he was humiliated John story
humiliated him and he like went into
some deep mental place like and then he
came out like is this new creature of
Truth and now he's like why was he I
disagree yeah like what he I don't think
he was I I disagree with you on that
does he has he said that's why he
transformed no this is just I don't
think Stewart uh humiliated him I
thought Stewart's uh performance was
even a little embarrassing because Jon
Stewart like he was calling Tucker
Carlson out for things that he claimed
were uh mistruthed and Tucker responded
by saying well actually you said this on
your show and that isn't true and Jon
Stewart goes it's a comedy show as if
Jon Stewart isn't trying to convince
people of things because he's just a
comedian it was really really slimy
duplicitous it was very duplicitous
because you can't have it both ways you
can't say like I do an educational
comedy show that teaches people things
and then when someone calls you out for
misinformation say let's it's a comedy
show who cares but that's exactly what
Jon Stewart it's just a joke when I say
a thing that happened is true followed
by a joke exactly exactly what Jon
Stewart and the rest of his ilk do is
they'll say here's a true thing that
happened and now joke and it's like then
they claim the lie was the joke the
whole time exactly so they'll say like
Sheamus was seen kicking dogs was the
dog which did happen but there's a
justification for it I don't want that
into right right so the point is they'll
say Sheamus kicked a dog and then that's
the fact and then they go and was the
dog Snoopy like some ridiculous nonsense
yeah and then everyone laughs and then
later they'll be like the whole thing
was a joke and you'll be like Sheamus
never kicked a dog it'd be like no we
were joking yeah exactly so they'll talk
about It Like It's News plus jokes and
then when they get called out for saying
something that wasn't true they go oh no
but it's just a joke what's the big deal
so I seem to remember Tucker this like
2003 four or five a while ago yeah he
was like just basically like the Warner
rack is good uh Barack Obama's bad and
all the Republicans are good and the
Democrats are bad and that was like not
I was in the zone of like Obama's good
you know war is bad but he was like but
we and something happened right around
that Jon Stewart interview with them
where he changed like he he disappeared
for a year came out and he lost the bow
tie and he got way more serious I missed
the bow tie I do miss the bow tie but uh
I know I remember that interview
you're right that Tucker Carlson was
very much like a typical like kind of
neocon broadcast well that's what the
bow tie was for so that when you were
looking at him and he was saying that we
need to go blow up foreigners you were
like put that bow ties like it's just so
funny it is a nice bow tie he's like I
tied it myself the other thing uh ideas
maybe he did a bunch of mushrooms one
day I don't think why is that always it
why can't someone just come to realize
something true without doing a bunch of
mushrooms wouldn't it be great
so that that interview made him like
change his opinions on the Iraq War I
don't think it does no Ian's just crazy
I'm just kind of throwing one out there
I don't know if it was that interview
but around that time of his life he kind
of had this change momentum he switched
all his opinions at some point not all
of them but like he he began to oppose
the um the kind of neo-conservative
foreign policy perspective because he
used to be very much in lockstep but the
rest of the right wing at that time
which was saying yes our freedom is over
in the Middle East let's go Osama Bin
Laden bad we were attacked 911 and
terrorists two airplanes I'm being snide
I'm being snied right but
neoconservatism is intellectually
bankrupt it's just a form of Marxism oh
I I feel like they just co-opted the
conservative movement this neo-war now
Trump kicked him out though I was so
young when all that stuff was going on
like I don't even how old were you in 06
uh I was 10. oh yeah we're like the same
age yeah yeah about the same age I
remember those did you watch that stuff
when you were back then I so I watched a
little bit Yeah my I used to you know
when we would drive anywhere we didn't
listen to music in the car it was always
talk radio always talk radio and so I
heard a lot of it my you know my dad is
one of those guys who he listens to both
sides uh at that time he definitely did
and so I heard uh unfortunately I I
heard my fair share of NPR as well but
yeah you know a lot of like Rush
Limbaugh Michael Savage uh the the OG's
yeah my dad used to listen to them too
but I didn't know what they were talking
about I was so confused I was like fire
like little 10 year old chambers of
Spider-Man
I was like Dad turn the radio off
scary man is yelling yeah
yeah I'm country I think part of Tucker
Tucker's like what I love about him is
that he used to be a neocon used to be
like in The Matrix and now he's out of
it like yeah I love the the retribution
story that come come from behind Victory
what do you what do you mean in The
Matrix because when we say that like we
talk about like dating and relationships
I'm curious what you guys it's in like
the political world well you explained
it first like what is what is the dating
Matrix
um it's just kind of like men grow up
thinking that like women want the guy
that gives them flowers treats them well
and they grow up and find out that's not
true right right and there's the red
pill there's they actually they get kind
of mad at me because there's so many
like people have so many different
definitions of it so they kind of argue
over it but that's like in layman's term
about the Matrix Yeah well yeah like the
red pill because a lot of people use
that word for so many different things
but but so I'm curious in the political
world what you guys mean like the
literal Matrix yeah I thought like
there's a there's so the political red
pill is there is a corporate there is a
corporate narrative that the average
person believes is reality and if you
are to quote unquote take the red pill
you wake up to the untruths that is the
corporate press the media politics for
the establishment narrative 911. like I
was fed I thought okay a couple of
planes hit the buildings they knocked
them down and Osama Bin Laden's the one
that's responsible for all of this okay
and then I found out later like oh
there's a lot of evidence that there's
more to it than in just a couple of
planes and this dude in the Middle East
I think Saudi Arabia got sued over their
involvement or something what was that I
don't know I don't know I don't want to
get into it because I don't know if
about it but there was like there's
there's a lot more that is a rabbit are
you guys like bushed at 9 11. no we
don't we don't all share the same
opinion we're actually pretty diverse
panel to be honest yeah yeah I don't
have any evidence of who did it but
there's a lot more going on than what I
thought like the way the buildings fell
down in near Free Fall is like but
instead of just getting into a whole 911
debate yeah
what the red pill is yeah I would say
for me like the political Matrix there's
a couple different things and I usually
don't use terms like the red pill or the
Matrix for the reason that you described
which is that they're thrown around by
so many people to represent so many
different things but I would say that in
one sense The Matrix is sort of like all
the the social political ideas that are
forced onto people that they're
convinced of that are untrue and I would
say one of those at least in the dating
Marketplace is just you know the sexual
Revolution more generally speaking this
idea that people are happy when they
have sex outside of marriage that this
is something people should aspire to do
and that it's a healthy way for man to
live and that we're just a product of
our own self-invention and as long as a
person is getting their sexual
gratification what they're doing is
beyond reproach basically
that's Matrix yeah that's definitely
Matrix that's like I would say so I
don't usually use that language yeah
that's how I was wondering but no
because well but it's also political
because the sexual Revolution is a
massively uh political thing it has a
strong political element to it and all
of our political establishments exactly
promote it it's a mix of the the like
it's it's a mix of the political and
dating yeah yeah well because the family
is the building block of society so
anything the movement has to well Reagan
played a role in the destruction of the
American family with no fault divorce he
didn't do it himself overnight man there
was a lot at work there but um I think
it was that was a misstep it was it's
it's hard to say with the final nails
but that was definitely very bad very
bad no fault no fault divorce ended
marriage it formalized it formalized our
ending of marriage but there were other
things like there was a massive cultural
shift that happened at this time so
previously people thought of divorce as
something that was horrible but that we
should allow in certain circumstances
and I'm not even saying that's the
correct vision because my I I just don't
believe a marriage can actually end if
it's an actual marriage but that's not
to say someone who's being abused can't
go live somewhere else but my main point
is there was there was uh there was a
there was a uh reinvention that happened
culturally or around the time of the
1970s where people stopped viewing
divorce as this unfortunate thing that
happened sometimes and that we should
allow a political outlet for and they
started reframing it as an adventure a
method of self-exploration a way to
reinvent yourself rather than like
something horrific that we should
prevent from from ever well I mean some
people say it's um birth control if you
look up yeah divorce rate and like birth
control like the rate of women on birth
control it's really interesting the the
charts are the same pretty much whoa
yeah well it all plays a role you could
look it up and like put it on the screen
it's really interesting it's like
literally if you put them side by side
it's the same I know that um but I smell
different I would say like social media
too because I I think like yeah because
I mean you get like all these women that
think they're hotter than they are
because they have the simps messaging
them every single day Instagram filters
yeah so I think like it would be silly
to not include that in like the
destruction of the family also is that
the destruction these women can't these
women still hook up with those Sims that
are messaging them what do you mean like
what about the fact that guys are
hitting on these women is different from
reality because it makes it makes a
global sexual Marketplace so it's not
she doesn't just have access to the men
like in her town because before it's
like the prettiest guy prettiest girl in
the town marry each other whatever now
it's like the men are competing with men
from you know Dubai like celebrities
like how many women has you know a
celebrity like Drake slept with we
actually future future wives you know
what I mean we've talked a lot about
this uh yeah I've and boy it doesn't
trigger the feminists I talked about how
uh dating apps oh that's basically
caused a major collapse because what
happens is it used to be that if you
were a dude you had access men and women
had access to their school basically the
institution where they spent all of
their time so a guy is 18 he goes to
college and he has access to the women
in the college network which is mostly
the college he's at and then maybe the
friends of friends yeah but when dating
apps emerge all of a sudden all of these
you know 18 plus young women have access
to 25 year old plus men who aren't in
college but have cars have jobs have
salaries and now the 18 year old in
college has to enter has to compete with
a guy who's already got a career and has
already established and they can't yeah
I think it's it's really important that
you pointed out birth control because
that plays a massive role in the way
that we've been restructured in terms of
our thinking about sexuality so people
used to recognize that the purpose of
sex was unity and procreation right and
you wanted to be with the person you
were going to be with the rest of your
life before you engage in that act with
them because it makes new people and
someone has to take responsibility for
those new people
what artificial contraceptives made
possible was a rerouting of our
Collective cultural thinking about
sexuality which took it from something
that was to be revered that was
beautiful that needed social
restrictions and something that was just
about the pleasure of the individual and
that only needed to be considered within
the context of pleasure without actually
considering its actual broader purpose
which is the creation of families and of
course families are the building block
of society so when you corrupt people's
sexual morals you end up destroying the
entire Society inevitably I mean if you
don't end up setting that that
um train back on the the rail or putting
things back in the proper course it all
falls apart you you just can't do it
um and you know we recognize this
economically whenever a Marketplace is
deregulated we say well this is going to
result in unbearable inequalities all of
the spoils will go to some small
percentage of people who happen to have
the traits that the market rewards but
then when it came to the sexual
Revolution no one was willing to say
that well when it comes to the sexual
Marketplace deregulating it is going to
create unbearable terrible inequalities
and in the end people aren't going to be
happy I get the feeling that if we made
birth control illegal and made abortion
illegal it would cause Devastation like
it would cause a bunch of spousal abuse
like a lot of the the value of I can't
stand no fault divorce I mean it makes
me I lost faith in marriage basically I
have no faith in that institution
because she can leave whenever she wants
but if they're stuck then won't they
just be getting beat a lot
um so if well this is the whole point of
no fault divorce is a person could get
divorced if they demonstrated that there
was some kind of abuse occurring right
and this is part of what I was saying
earlier I believe marriage is life long
but that doesn't mean that you can't go
live somewhere else if a person is
abusing you right that doesn't mean you
don't go and go to the police well and
the one thing too they've expanded the
definition of abuse so much that we
don't even know what abuse is anymore
like it's not like that you can include
like Financial abuse because I'm doing a
divorce documentary and and so um it's
going into like basically men that get
financially ruined by divorce and the
issue is like they literally like have
expanded the definition so much to
include things like Financial abuse so
if I'm married and he says you can't
spend five thousand dollars on my credit
card he's financially controlling me and
that's considered abuse and family court
you need to give in the US percentage of
your income UK um us is state by state
wow so uh like this is this is based in
the UK well words are violence now so
yeah exactly do you think there's faith
in marriage do you have faith in
marriage well I don't think marriage is
marriage anymore
like I I think that marriage it's a
whole different institution it's
basically just long-term relationships
nowadays it's dating I think that's
there's truth in that yeah because like
if you can get out like how is it
marriage I think the way is marriage
doesn't exist since no-fault divorce
yeah I I would argue that in the United
States our laws don't properly recognize
marriage of course I believe marriage
still exists but the way the culture
understands it you're not looking at
actual marriages in a sense because the
person isn't truly saying uh For Better
or For Worse till death do we part
they're saying I'm just going to do this
for a while until I get bored about like
if if divorce is in your mind as an
option it's something you're willing to
consider and you're not saying there is
no one else for me for the rest of my
life or this person's life then are you
really getting married there's a in the
service industry I used to work as a
waiter for like a decade and when we
would finish a shift I'd marry the
condiments and be like okay take the
ketchups and marry them together which
means mix I'd pour one into the other
shake it up you could never undo that
that mix is permanent now one flesh the
two became one flesh and what what does
a guy get out of marriage that he
doesn't get out of a long-term
girlfriend if she can leave her half her
money yeah well again I think the um
what do you mean half her money like I
guess in the instance of like wasn't the
story with Russell Brand that when they
got he got divorced from Katy Perry he
didn't take anything from her because
they're both super rich and he didn't
care yeah well I mean women get money
the majority of the time so it's not
like men get money out of it yeah like I
think I think when
bows will support like 10 of the time
when it comes to child like child
custody women get the kids 90 of the
time yeah so it's really an unfair
system totally agree so your question
has two different answers right when you
ask what do men get out of marriage
because in some sense like yes when
you're talking about our society when
you're talking about what we are calling
marriage I mean because the institution
yeah yeah if we're talking about what
marriage actually is it's a different
question right I mean because it's again
it's not moral to have sex with someone
you're not married so you shouldn't be
having sex with someone you're not
married to in a culture where people are
having sex outside of marriage where
they're living together when they're not
married you're correct that uh it
doesn't seem from like a material
perspective that anything is really
added to the relationship by entering
into a legal Union with each other well
even when you look at like you know
Purity and youth like men don't even get
that anymore out of marriage like in the
UK the average age of first marriage for
a girl is 31. and when I like security
like what percent of women do you think
were virgins in 1920.
um many more than today I don't know if
it was 100 but it was there there's been
surveys done and many more women I mean
you don't know like people can lie but
it was like 85 of women
um did not like they said their virgins
on their wedding day like what is that
today so what what does a guy get from
Marriage yeah so he doesn't get Purity
doesn't get youth um now she has the
power to take I mean but that's that is
more of a traditionalist argument that
doesn't I don't think matters
materialistically or um
what I'm saying is there are certainly
people who care about purity and all
that stuff I don't think the average
person thinks like is my wife pure but a
lot of guys probably do what I'm saying
is you go to a guy and say Hey you know
that long-term relationship you're in
yes why don't you get married okay why
well if you do you open up the door to
losing half of everything you own if
things go bad and nothing else changes
what does the woman get the woman gets
half your stuff if she decides to leave
at any point well but this is also the
point right the left Marxist they they
hate marriage and they hate the family
so people look at how the culture has
been oriented and they look at these no
fault divorce laws and they say oh my
goodness there's no point in even
getting married anymore well that was by
Design like the entire purpose was to
dissuade people from wanting to get
married that was the long game that was
the long game and make it and so I think
our marriage is okay exactly right
because if if sex before marriage is on
the table then you can have that without
committing to a person I mean what are
most men gonna choose even if you don't
have these wacky diverse Force laws
although divorce in the marriage stuff
aside I find it weird to say that sex
before marriage is bad because like if
you have if you don't if you have sex or
girl and you don't like it but you don't
know that until after you're married
that'd be horrible well sex isn't
tryouts right and she she's a person and
you're a person and that's a an act that
creates human people and it'll create a
person even if you didn't think the sex
was uh all that great I think that two
people who are married should should try
uh to communicate with one another so
that they could you know meet each
other's needs in illicit way and uh I
think we've created so many problems
with no fault divorce in this sexual
Evolution and sex outside a marriage to
say that you know a solution to that
problem isn't good enough because it
might interfere with some people's
ability to have sexual pleasure doesn't
really convince me well and it's not
even about like moral like good or bad
it's like what outcomes does what
outcomes does this have and like the
studies show that the best outcomes are
from two people that are both virgins
but the best outcomes of marriage yeah
that's true and marriage satisfaction
yeah how would you know if the sex was
bad if you didn't have sex with anyone
else exactly that's the same exact
argument feminists make they were like
wow that must suck condemning your life
to bad sex because you live this
puritanical way yeah yeah
okay yeah but again that's that's a
horrible way of viewing sex it's a
horrible way of ignoring other people
and well it's not just that ignorance is
bliss it's that there are some things
you have no need to know but right like
it doesn't there is some information
that's not going to make you happier
there are a lot of things that all of us
could know that we don't want to know
because it would make us miserable a
five-minute orgasm would be awesome like
if you could have non-stop orgasms with
your wife like it's just you could do
like two hours of tantrics if you think
with sex outside of marriage that's
happening for people because the studies
show that people rate lower marital
satisfaction rates when they've had more
sexual partners prior to marriage have
you ever have you ever watched any
romantic comedy yeah like the Trope is
that the women are always unsatisfied
like the guys are in it for a one-night
stand it's wham bam thank you ma'am and
they leave well and also they're not to
get I mean since we're already having an
adult conversation here they have done
studies with Rams right so this is
something that I learned when I was
looking into the effects that
pornography has in the brain and how men
will seek out novelty and they found
with these Muse that they were studying
that men finished more quickly with a
newer partner okay so exactly so I I
don't think I have to elaborate any
further on the implications of that it's
not just that I think that if you have
two people who care about each other
it's likely going to be better between
them than a guy who's like can I get
this woman in the closet for a few
minutes yeah there is I think there's a
problem of chasing the orgasm that's
that's I think my mom would be like your
dad just he's obsessed with sex oh my
God he just loves that and I'm like well
okay maybe I gotta not do that then but
like on the other side it is pretty epic
you know like a good orgasm is like what
I don't think anything else in the world
can compete with that
uh maybe not a good meal I mean maybe a
good meal if you're hungry I'm sure
everybody in the comment is going to say
the same face they're gonna say the face
seeing the face of your child for the
first time oh yeah good point Ian
doesn't have kids I was actually
thinking that today raising kids is far
superior like having a family as far as
just just being with people and you're
better off in a committed relationship
with someone who you know won't just up
and leave and take everything and your
kids from you and that's the other thing
too with with no fault divorce you have
no guarantee you get to keep your kids
there's just like the family has been
completely destroyed and there is a
tremendous risk in having kids because
they could just take your kids from you
and then destroy your life what is the
only there's only 11 states that have
automatic 50 50 custody out of 50. so
it's like if it's 50 it's DNA why
doesn't he get 50 custody off the bat
well there was a there was a story at
Wisconsin where a guy who wasn't even
the Father the woman claimed he was and
the courts ordered him to pay child
support because she listed him as the
father and the DNA proved he wasn't
there we don't care kidney to death wow
yeah what do you think Pearl what do you
think is like a solution to this no
Vault divorce situation oh I think we
should ban divorce
ban it completely exactly like what if a
guy's beating his wife
if he's beating his wife I think I think
there's an exception to every rule but I
don't think that makes the rule
um but you know what you know what else
do you know what else they don't talk
about when they look at one-sided abuse
women hit men more than men hit women so
it's the women that are beating their
husbands more than the husbands are
beating their wife one it's one-sided
because the majority of abuse cases is
mutual and the other thing they don't
talk about and I'm so tired of this on
the show these girls will come on and
say I was abused I was abused and I used
to just believe women right because it's
like and it's kind of a sensitive it's
kind of awkward in the room and
someone's like oh I was abused but it's
like if you're bringing it up on the
show I'm gonna ask you questions right
you clearly want you talked about it so
and then I would ask questions and I'd
realize these girls were not talking
about the part they had to play in the
abuse I'll give you an example one girl
she says I was abused so I say okay what
happened how how because I'm thinking
like the average guy can beat me the
hell I'd be dead like the hour and I'm I
deadlift 300 pounds I'm a semi-pro
athlete I had Pro contracts in the fall
I'm six foot like I'm pretty built for
for a chick right and I'm still saying
the average guy can beat me up so I'm
like okay if he was beating you like
that like where is where are your
injuries right so I asked her what
happened she says well he pushed me like
he pushed me down the stairs or
something like that and I was like okay
well why like what led up to this and
you know come to find out
this girl wouldn't leave so she refused
to use trespassing on this guy's house
wouldn't leave and then he pushes her
out of the house that's abuse
that's abuse is that actually with what
he did was was that legal to push her
out of the house did he push her down
the stairs though because that's
different from like trying to remove
someone from your problem that's what
she was trying to do that's what he was
like I don't yeah
well don't push people downstairs yeah
yeah I don't think he meant to like the
way she was saying is like she was like
she wouldn't leave so what are you
supposed to do she now you could call
the cops but I'm saying it wasn't this
like you probably thought you got to
call the police yeah yeah because
because you have to protect yourself but
my point is she didn't talk about like
my point isn't like was it abuse wasn't
it abuse my point is women don't talk
about the part they have to play in it
yeah so you know you know what I do I
just I would just go in my room lock the
door call the police say I gotta break
him that's it I mean yeah yeah but it is
like a person who enters your property
without your permission and I'd say
there's an ongoing burglar I've locked
myself in my room you guys can build it
because what will happen is if you try
to physically remove her and the cops
show up she'll say help help I'm being
abused and you will get arrested right
so just go in your room lock the door
I'm not saying run and cower I'm saying
just separate yourself from this person
and then call the police and be like
please come burglary in progress then
they'll come in and find the lady
screaming and ranting and you'll be like
I am in the other room door's locked man
all right well and the other thing is
like as I was saying before what they
did um and this is more um pertaining to
the UK um not the us but I know some
states have similar laws to this they've
basically expanded the definition of
abuse to include things like coercive
control Financial abuse I mean they have
like a list of like five to I think ten
and it's a point system so basically
what happens is if you like maybe two
times he said you were financially
abused
um three times you you were coercively
controlled like they even say they were
graped like early on in the relationship
or something like that that even though
they would like stay for later and if
you get like I don't know maybe it's
seven points out of ten like then that's
like considered abusive we have grapes
growing on the property this is crazy no
joke you gotta check them out like
actual grapevines with and you can see
the grapes coming in careful but if you
eat the skin before washing it off
there's a lot of like apparently you
gotta freeze them or something they're
called Frost grapes I don't know
anything about it yeah I had a similar
situation yeah well I didn't know if you
could say that on the show you could say
grape on on YouTube well I don't I don't
know but so like when it comes to abuse
like if it's a genuinely abusive
situation sure like we divorce fine fine
but like I think it's more of the
exception than the rule because even
people that work at abuse like centers
will tell you the majority of abuse
cases they're both abusing each other so
it's not just one-sided so at that point
it's just like a toxic relationship
maybe they should like take some time
apart and like I wanna I wanna come back
to a lot of the subject because we we do
have another uh story to talk about we
have a lot of stories to talk about and
then we'll come back to the dating stuff
but um speaking of believing women we
have this story Elliot page reveals
chilling transphobic attack outside La
Hotel quote I'm going to effing gay
bashu and then homophobic slur and then
the guy apparently uh in the most
prominent gay neighborhood probably in
the country of which is West Hollywood
in Los Angeles well maybe it's maybe San
Francisco got more problems
yeah but but L.A West Hollywood is one
of the most prominent gay neighborhoods
in the country this is where Elliot page
was and then after this person said this
followed Elliot page into a store called
Pink Dot and then said this is why I
need a gun it's amazing I can't believe
it this story coming out on the same day
that Elliott page has released their new
book
so uh nobody believes the story I mean
come on so a guy was walking around Los
Angeles in in literally The Boys Town of
Los Angeles and was shocked and outraged
to see someone who he assumed was gay
and then specifically said gay bash and
then this is why I need a gun like it it
best fan fiction it's bad fan fiction
for liberals guns are bad see that's why
they want guns who who is that I don't
know who that is Elliot page yeah
formerly Ellen Page
have you ever seen Juno yeah that that
was uh the girl from Juno yeah yeah yeah
and she transitioned to oh that's so
Elliott about yeah and then there's a
there's a big question about whether or
not Elliot page has fake implants for
the yeah that's gotta be fair a lot of a
lot of people are saying like if you
look at Ellie Page's arms it doesn't
when you when you work out your your
core for abs there's a uh whenever you
work on a muscle there's like a 30
transference to the surrounding muscles
because all muscles are working it's not
just like when you're like working out
your arms you're actually using a bunch
of other muscles too so you would have
muscle development in other areas so a
lot of people are like Elliot page got
implants to look like a dude with abs or
whatever I just think this person's a
liar well this story I think I think
they they're suffering from severe
depression I think that was publicly
known and I think that results in
Desperate cries for attention like the
most ridiculous story you've ever heard
I'm sorry it's I don't know what's more
ridiculous jussie smolletto for this to
be fair it is possible this happened the
Justice Millet thing is kind of like yo
get out of here that's even worse yeah
Chicago 2 A.M Sub-Zero weather two guys
carrying bleach and a string from a
hardware store this is maybe there was a
crazy homeless guy muttering and
sputtering and rambling and then SAR you
know but he did not use that for next if
he did not say I am going to gay bash
you like that's not that's not how
people talk that's not a thing anybody's
like no if if Elliot page claimed the
guy said oh I'm going you disgust me I'm
gonna get you or something I'd be like
okay that makes more sense this kind of
reminds me what we're just talking about
how we only get potentially half the
story what led up to this interaction
was Elliot screaming at the guy because
if she's a miserable depressed person I
wouldn't put it past well him I wouldn't
put it past him to to wail on someone
verbally okay maybe
um there was a unicorn that was flying
to the sky and it pooped and the poop
landed on this gigantic Behemoth of an
angry man who then turned and saw Elliot
pay age picking flowers for Elliot's
mother and then went oh boy I'm so angry
oh boy
because if we're just gonna make things
up I'll make up whatever I want if she's
gonna make something up I'll just make
up how it started there you go there's
the story what do you think Pearl well I
have a question I I don't know if I can
say this or not oh I don't write it on a
piece of paper
[Music]
you can write it on a paper yeah
don't brag I just have a question but I
don't know if this question will okay oh
she's writing a race too hot for TV I I
don't know I can't believe you oh my
gosh look wait wait wait you said this
Sheamus is sweating like this is this is
a close-up on Sheamus's eyeballs I feel
like it's going to be a very innocuous
question I don't think it's that bad but
I just don't wanna I don't it's your
guys's shows what I basically said was
oh so I I I I will check with Tim but
I'm pretty sure yes I'll just ask him
it's one of these things for those that
are wondering what we're talking about
basically what we tell people is I don't
know if you can but it's true I don't
know if you can say that but it's yeah
I'm pretty sure you can say it you
you're not so on YouTube you do not
insult someone based on their immutable
characteristics okay outside of that
you're fine what about questioning their
mental stability is that okay I'm pretty
sure that uh Elliot Pages publicly
expressed they have mental illness oh
okay so why are we taking like the word
seriously of someone that's mentally ill
like why are they getting articles and
stuff I think I think Ellie page has
specifically talked about severe
depression and anxiety and disorders and
things like that I could be wrong it
could be wrong but um
I was like this story comes out the same
day the book is getting released this is
not this is not mental illness this is
this is cold calculating marketing wow
I think it's just
crazy why did Jesse Smollett do with
Justin because he was renegotiating his
contract on Empire and he wanted to be a
hot ticket item and why now is this
story come out June 6 is the release
date for page boy the new book what a
weird marketing strategy right the the
new like fake hate crime marketing firm
out there that's telling these people
that this will help their Public Image
but it makes sense right because we live
in a victimhood culture and we want
people to sympathize with you you have
to be a victim because that would make
That's What Makes You impressive yeah
I'm real Fed Up on the victimhood
culture it's getting under my skin
just now no no no no totally I just
wanted to do you get that do you
constantly interact with victims on the
on your show oh my God
I just think women nowadays just want to
be victim it's like everything like I've
never heard a girl come on a show
because we talk about relationships a
lot and just so you know what that
relationship was my fault yeah I've
never heard a girl say that oh there was
a story today uh I was reading in the
Daily Mail and it was a woman crying
because her fiance left her and said it
was my fault because I wouldn't listen
to why he was upset and I was too
stubborn to compromise and now he's gone
yeah and it made news headlines
if you ask a guy like he had a nice girl
he maybe cheated on her he'll kind of
admit it he'll be like you know what
yeah I was a dog I was this but it's
like girls just find the craziest ways
to make themselves the victim in every
relationship oh my gosh that's hilarious
in every gosh and I used to not really
understand like why guys were
complaining about dating so much I was
like why are the guys complaining like
why why are they saying this is so bad
and then I started doing the show and I
was like oh my gosh it's worse than I
thought it's like one the girls are so
flaky coming on the show I've never been
really flaked on by guys women it's like
50 I literally have to book it really 50
50. if they'll show up I booked double
the amount of women because I know half
full cancel are they probably really are
they no are you being hyperbolic or is
it really half half I mean I don't I
haven't recruited in a while but when I
did the recruiting myself yeah I and we
book uh 10 girls for the show we have
give our recruiters 10 slots and so like
the that's like the most mics we have we
expect like half to come it's for one
show you'll have ten invites yeah 10
invites
um I mean sometimes we add in guys too
so like they're guys it depends on the
show but yeah that's wild so half the
time they just don't show up do you
think though is it is it something about
like your show being more controversial
that it makes them feel more frightened
to do no this was even before I was bit
like this was like I like I started at
15 I was at 15 000 Subs a year ago
well people think it was the show but it
actually wasn't the show well sort of I
would do a show right and we would talk
about like
I don't know maybe the pay Gap not being
real or like not not the way they think
right like basic like kind of red pill
truths right and I would see a girl
where like the wheels were sort of
turning where she was kind of
understanding what I was saying when I
would say like you know the reason for
the pay Gap is because we don't work as
many hours we don't do as dangerous job
like you know et cetera we flake on
podcasts that kind of thing yeah yeah
and so what I would do is I would invite
the girls back and I would show them
like um a red pilling like video so one
of the First videos that went viral was
I read pulled my friend for the first
time and it was like um a 45 minute
video of Jordan Peterson arguing with
that feminist on the pay Gap right and
so but these would be like these would
be like three hour conversations really
in-depth like just like where I'm like
slowly sort of like deconstructing what
they believe and you know because at one
point like I mean I I thought the pickup
was real like I mean not not any time
recently but yeah you're when you're
younger right and so that's what
initially blew it up was like it would
be like red pilling women in real time I
found it that's what I found it but the
story is real but also um Don King on
women does as well too a woman left by
her fiance burst into tears as she
confesses the one mistake she made and
she basically says that they would get
into fight I was too good for a failure
to address the problems caused them to
escalate and ultimately neither was
willing to make sacrifices or compromise
on their stance after the relationship
ended cam realized that she should have
been less stubborn and tried to
appreciate her partner's Viewpoint and
now she's now she's alone dang and it
made news headlines yeah why I mean I
guess that's a big deal for modeling it
was like woman admits fault yeah it's a
it's a sad story it happens
um I think that uh part of what this
culture does is it creates this Warfare
between men and women and of course the
man is always the bad guy everything's
his fault and you see this repeatedly
immediate I mean I
even from singers even from male singers
you hear so many songs that men sing
about how they messed up and they did
something wrong I can't think of a
single pop song written by a woman about
how like she wasn't good enough for the
guy she was with you get a lot of songs
like that written by male pop stars
trying to think of one yeah now and and
you see this Trope in film and
television all the time it's always the
guy begging the girl to come back to him
because he messed up holding the stereo
yeah and then his trench coat while it
rains baby come back and yeah it's it's
never the opposite it's never the
opposite movies typically follow two
tropes one it's the guy saving the girl
or two it's the guy apologizing to the
girl
for women women love that yeah they
don't
they want she had a whole family with
another I know she's evil and she's
still talking about her ex-lover she met
for like a lover whatever her one night
stand no this is
but this is very real right the Titanic
is an unbelievably Evil film but there's
something masterful about the way that
the cinematography the framing and the
music is used to make you sympathize
with someone who's a genuinely bad
person like she doesn't have a character
she doesn't go from a bad person to a
good person she goes from like a selfish
person to a person who's like a selfish
person but who's selfish in a different
way when you look I just want to mention
one thing what she does I saw this movie
years ago so you know take this with a
grain of salt but what I remember is she
cheats on her fiance and then has the
homeless guy she's cheating on him with
draw a picture of her naked wearing her
engagement gift and then she puts it in
his safe with like a snide remark right
now like that psychopath behavior that
is not what a normal person does that is
insane and people watch this they're
like wow her story is inspiring she's a
demon wasn't she like talking to her
granddaughter or something she was on
the boat and then no no no no she was
talking to treasure Hunters who were
looking for the diamond she had was she
rose on the boat she's at a boat that
cost millions of dollars hundreds of
thousands of rent and they're asking her
to tell this boring old lady story she
only tells because they think she has a
diamond and she has it and she throws it
off the ship she hasn't given to the
people who listen to her for hours she
doesn't sell it to take care of her her
granddaughter who spent her life caring
for her and doesn't have a family of her
own she throws it off the ship because
Jack needed it
died in the bottom of the ocean and you
know it's crazy that's crazy she was on
the boat she was on the safety boat
right and she jumps off the safety boat
back into the real belt Jack would be
alive if she just stayed in the original
safety boat that saves her later exactly
right he there would have been rumor
then there was room on the door dude
they don't tell you the report of the
story but I bet you I bet you jack when
he saw she's almost still on the boat
was like
yeah no I can save both of us I can say
but yes fine just come just but I think
uh uh they've proven now that uh who's
the guy who did the movie what's his
name James Cameron yeah Cameron they he
did a thing where they got the two
people to sit on the door and it worked
and they're like yeah that was like you
know that was weird you know what other
movies like this too The Notebook I
remember being a kid watching this movie
and thinking like he's he's cheating she
why is this okay yeah and they
romanticized cheating but you know what
I think it is I think it's like what's
that one about I don't know the notebook
basically she it's Again The One That
Got Away which is also a Katy Perry song
right but basically she dates this guy
in high school and they're in love or
whatever and then she they break up I
don't remember why but she goes on to
meet this really nice guy that like
traded her well all this stuff similar
you know to the Titanic but she just
couldn't get the old guy out of her head
and she goes and cheats on him for like
three days and then he like runs in the
rain and is like I love you and then she
leaves her fiance for this guy she dated
in high school she's an alpha Widow bro
I actually never saw it but I had a
podcast guest who was explaining the
plot of it to me I was like this is this
is horrible yeah horrible Story the
alpha the alpha Widow is like it's it's
really common in music and movies can we
do like a sequel to every Hallmark movie
ever where it's like so the woman who's
got a fiance and he's like a snooty
business this man and then she goes back
home to see her parents and then there's
the the nerdy guy who's all grown up and
Suave and he's like a carpenter now and
he's ripped and then he's very nice to
her and she realized he was the one all
along can we just have like a part two
where it's like they had a one night
stand and he was like yo I'm done like I
got things to do yeah I've seen you in
20 years later produce it I'll be I'll
act yeah no this happens
right every human being has a tendency
to wonder is the grass greener on the
other side and what Hollywood has done
is built an entire sub-industry of
telling women yes it is actually on the
other side go check it out no it's gonna
be great you're gonna love your time
over there and then you end up uh
Divorced with a broken family or with a
person who actually doesn't treat you
very well and this isn't addressed and
we just keep churning out media that's
horribly irresponsible it should just be
like the day after she gets the the
hometown hero guy and she leaves her
snooty businessman fiance he like wakes
up and he's like I think you should
probably go and she's like what do you
mean I thought we were having
something's like no I was just saying
that so that you'd sleep with me you can
leave now but why why would Hollywood
producers want women to think the
hard-working man who's loyal to them is
bad for trying to stop weird strangers
from sleeping with her why would
Hollywood producers want women to have
that in their head I keep saying
Hollywood but it's home Mark Hollywood
Hallmark all of it but I think I think
made in Canada Hallmark is like way over
the line but all of these Hollywood
movies follow similar tropes like the
man who meets all of society's standards
for what a responsible man is isn't good
enough we either depict him as being
like you know bad in some emotional way
you know there's there's always a catch
the good hard-working man always has
problems and like The Lovable loser
always has a heart of gold and genuinely
cares for you it's like sorry no well
and the other thing is like whenever
they always try to like explain women's
cheating so like whenever you say oh she
cheated they always say well why did he
cheat what did he do it's the same thing
if she freaks out and is like hitting a
guy it's always like what did he do what
did he do to deserve this like they're
the default is he deserved this in some
way where it's like if a man cheats he's
a dog he's evil he's just you know
whatever yeah but like yeah here's the
thing like now we're seeing all these
polyamorous relationships because
cheating kind of only really applies to
marriage and what we've created now is
this pseudo hybrid dating marriage thing
so here's how it used to be it was a a
young woman would date several men what
does that really mean it means they'd go
out for a cheeseburger and a milkshake
and then if they were like Hey we're
really getting along and we have a lot
in common this is fun they would decide
to get married now dating is first you
meet at a bar and then you bang at her
place or his place then they decide hey
maybe we should do this more often so
you've already like jumped the line into
like living together and hooking up but
there's no actual commitment so it's all
just
a mishmash yeah exactly so so what is
cheating well cheating was like you were
married marriage is a contract the
reason it's called cheat is because you
have a commitment you are breaking if
you're just like randomly dating some
floozy or something like how is it
cheating if you don't have anything
formally set anyway and you could leave
at any time well I would add one thing I
would say like if you are dating someone
monogamously to discern marriage and
they can't be monogamous through the
courtship process that does tell you
something about them it's like all right
yeah you're not the one for me yeah but
I mean from from your standard Sheamus
they're like the person you're dating is
not going around having sex with a bunch
of dudes no it's also true yes so
there's not at least if she does I don't
know about it but what are you saying
like if you're if you would never date a
woman like that if you're so dating a
woman is like you're going out for
dinner and you're going to the movies
and then one day you find out she went
out to a movie with Ian and I would be I
would be like your first movie
they're going to see what is a woman and
I'm like apparently a liar and a cheater
I could tell Matt Walsh what a woman is
if you were in a relation relationship
with or if you just met a girl that just
rocked you knocked you on your ass
awesome but then you found out she did
it with 100 other guys would you still
be like whatever I'm going for it
there's a good question so um
statistically speaking we know that the
more sexual partners a person has the
higher the probability that they will
end up being divorced so I would say
there's kind of an imprudence in not
considering a person's history uh 100 is
a very big number I think like someone
can make mistakes genuinely repent and
then do the hard work to try to do the
Penance and fasting and prayer to
straighten themselves out and become
like a good holy person who would be a
worthy mother to one's children but
um I mean after a hundred I think that's
going to be pretty difficult I'm not
saying it's impossible but I'm saying
that it's not something that shouldn't
be considered and I think there are a
lot of people who want to argue that
that shouldn't be considered in it it
should yeah it's like do you decide with
your brain or with your heart you the
thing you have to think about and this
is this isn't me speaking as a married
man because I'm not married but I was
recently speaking to uh Jason Evert who
is and talks about these things and I
asked
he went to my high school really he
talked to your high school yeah he did
he did he's selling women dreams that
man yeah yeah I
I do like him but that's always the same
Trope with like the religious people
it's always like the ran through check
and like the guy that was a virgin that
like marries her at the end and she only
really gets away with it typically
because she's hot so which is kind of
stuff yeah that's a high representation
of his musician but yeah
it happened like he's a nice guy but oh
that's what you're saying no I I think
that's a horrible thing to say about him
and his wife well no I'm saying like
that's what he said I mean I don't I
don't know like I'm not trying to make
it a personal thing but can I can I
finish basically like that's what like
the wife goes up first and she talks
about how she was like slept with all
these people and then the guy goes up
and talks about how he didn't and then
the girl like gets married at the end
and yeah that's it's always the same
thing like so the girl basically gets
ran through and then the guy marries her
after and I'm like it's kind of selling
dreams and like an attractive girl can
get away with it but like the average
check it's like but but but I think
there's an important contextual
difference which is that Jason and his
wife aren't saying like go do this and
it'll be fine what they're saying was
like this was a horribly damaging thing
to do she wished she had never done it
and she repented and got close to Christ
and like did the work to undo her scars
and if it's genuine sure but I just
think like the issue like why I think a
lot of times Church like attracts women
that like hat like that are a bit slug I
mean come on like let's just be honest
like there's a reason there's Catholic
girls have a reputation there's a reason
Church girls have her
who are supposedly raised in the faith
aren't they're told they're Catholic and
they don't go to church they don't well
I I think it's two because like the
church kind of sells them dreams that
you can do all this stuff and still have
a guy waiting for you at the end and
like now and the data just doesn't
support it it's like 50 of women are
going to be single and childless
it very much sounds like the life of sin
followed by a death bad repentance
Christianity no no no because there's a
difference there's like and this is one
of the distinctions you have to make and
part of why I brought up Jason Everett
is because what he said to me when I
asked him this question on air was the
question you need to ask yourself is
like what could you tolerate 10 years
from now in a relationship with this
person and that is going to be partially
defined by that person's wounds the
things that they've done in their past
so a person having
a very unfortunate sexual history
doesn't just or even necessarily mean
that they're going to cheat on you or be
promiscuous they could end up being
monogamous and faithful but they could
still end up having all sorts of scars
with respect to the way they view sex
with the way they view the opposite sex
they can become an angry nasty person
because of it and you want to know that
there's someone who has worked through
it there's no denying that it is better
to be a virgin right but not everyone is
and God calls people to marry
non-virgins as well well yeah but I
think my point is that it's like they
just sort of like I think sometimes the
church sort of sells the dreams to women
because it's like you're kind of asking
a guy like to me something that's a bit
unreasonable like he why would he wait
when you slept with x amount of men like
for free well I think and I never and I
never see the church like like really
calling out like hey do not marry women
that aren't virgins I've never heard
like do not like they're red flag if she
slept with this many people I've never
really heard that so it's interesting
like they'll I really don't no no well
there's a couple different things to
pull apart there I mean firstly uh your
CR I mean I've never heard anyone say
don't marry a a non-virgin
how could they yeah in this day and age
that's just that's not so much a church
thing as much as that is like this is
something people won't say one thing we
do believe in is repentance and that a
person can restore themselves with the
help of Christ uh God can restore people
if you cooperate with him but
and I I would add one detail which is
that it doesn't say like men stay a
virgin women sleep around and then get
married it tells everyone to remain a
virgin and it will also tell women by
the way that like the man you're with uh
he might have slept around he might like
have had struggles with a porn addiction
that's real the issue is though like
women have so much more like like
obviously power on the sexual market
like there's so much more opportunity to
do it from a young age right so you're
going to have women that have slept
around and men that are a bit naive and
they don't know how to like like if you
have a guy that's a virgin and a woman
that slept with I don't know like
however many people right like he's
going to be naive and he won't really be
able to pick up on like certain red
flags I think no I look I think there's
some truth and I think the church
doesn't really talk about like the the
baggage like they don't really like talk
about the baggage that comes with this
stuff and like warning men about
predatory women because there are
predatory women I totally agree with you
look I totally agree with that there are
predatory women I think it's a big
statement to say the church doesn't warn
people about this because I know plenty
Catholics play plenty of Catholics who
would say like yes stay a virgin try to
marry a virgin I also know others who
say it's important to be yeah yeah okay
well I know nice well and I also know
people who would say it's good to be
equally yoked right like yeah if you
don't think you could handle that if
you're a virgin and this person uh has
slept with a lot of people that that is
something you consider in your
discernment it's not to say like you're
evil because you don't want to marry
someone who's not a virgin I don't think
there's anything can we talk about what
only fans does to society because you
know we were talking about this
downstairs like a couple days ago it's
basically all of these young women are
deciding that they want to be
prostitutes it's just like it's it's
like a digital version of it but it's
basically the same thing men can
subscribe to pay you money in exchange
for this Behavior there was this uh clip
that's going viral right now I think
clown World reposted it from the
whatever podcast where a woman says that
she was hooking up with a guy just to
break his heart
right yeah and then and then you know
the dude from whatever is like
she says her hobby is the humble man and
he's like and someone says you're a
stripper yeah he says it yeah and then
she's like yeah but I take their money
and it's like no listen I feel like a
lot of what we're talking about what
you're describing with um dudes who have
like addictions porn addictions and you
mentioning like women getting run
through whatever and then only fans and
stripping is that people are doing
things that are genuinely detrimental
across the board throughout the society
not just related to dating yeah and
there are people who don't want to feel
bad about it because misery loves
company so they tell everybody what
you're doing is totally fine keep doing
it even though it's really bad and the
obvious example the the actual visible
example is morbid obesity like we know
that if you are eating and gorging
yourself you will die sooner and we
don't want that we want you to live a
long healthy life but the people who
enjoy eating hot fudge sundaes all day
every day don't want to stop they're
addicted so instead of accepting and
admitting themselves they have a problem
they seek out validation from other
people who are addicted creating the
Society of people who are engaging in
extremely detrimental behaviors across
the board which brings me back to only
fans I I've met women who have said
they've tried it and they gave up
because they weren't making money and
now they have a bunch of poor online
it's everywhere they were like people
people stole the videos people recorded
the videos people did a whole bunch of
stuff and they made like 17 and that was
it and that there you are your your
prostitute forever never never you can
never change it yeah I mean the I can't
remember what the average amount of
money is for a woman that goes on only
fans but it's not a lot I thought it was
like 20 bucks or something yeah it's not
I wish I don't remember what it is but I
remember thinking like wow that's such a
low payout but it's also why are there
so any amount is enough for someone to
do that in this culture like I I think
Sheamus women and men are very very
different yeah and it is sad but
consider there's tons of stories of
women quitting their jobs to become
prostitutes or like marrying into money
I mean it's basically similar kind of
thing if you don't love the guy sure
gold digging but it's it's still
different to marry someone like to enter
into a binding contract granted now with
no fault divorce it is kind of
meaningless it used to be like you got
married you were there till the dude
died and then okay Al Pacino's like 90
he's got a 28 9 year old wife or
something and she's pregnant yep man the
wild oh you know in defense of uh only
fans I think it was evilovia was talking
about this because she did it uh you
porn and the porn industry girls
you can't guarantee that they're not 18
uh in the porn industry it's very
difficult to vet the process so there's
a lot of child porn that gets through in
that system whereas on only fans it's
vetted a hundred percent so you know
everything on there is legal and above
board I'm not I'm not opposed to porn
generally like I'm fairly libertarian
people can do their thing my issue is
there is a social Trend among many women
there's like a story of like a nurse
like I was a nurse making 50 000 year
and I quit now I make 200 doing porn
like
is is this a good thing I I don't think
it is like I don't know maybe maybe I I
should start reading some more books by
sex positive feminists no that is the
last thing that you should do that
I think women lie too about how much
they make because I went on the whatever
podcast and there was like I don't know
four or five girls that said they made
over 20k a month and I ran the numbers
and it was like less than 2 000 people
or 3 000 people in the U.S make the
number of like make the money they're
saying they make them like what are the
odds they're all on one show I think
there's some incentive to lie about it
oh absolutely well yeah well that's also
a fair point and it's a sad thing
because because a person might be
embarrassed how embarrassing would that
be oh my gosh you put your body on the
internet and you can't get 10 buyers
this is this is the reality of it yeah
so so there are a few there are people a
few people I know I know one woman who
did uh cam girl stuff and she literally
thought that she would be making she see
these stories the here's the crazy thing
these stories encourage more women to do
it and it never works so you get these
women to go on these shows and say I'm
making 20K a month and they're not and
then I have a friend who's like I'm
gonna try doing it and I'm like yeah you
probably shouldn't do that it's not
going to work out and then when what did
she say said all it was was people
sending messages saying please post for
free please post for free I want a free
sample and then she made like 17 and was
like this is this is nuts like there's
no money here but now everything's out
there well ins oh go ahead well and the
girl on the show I looked at her only
fans I mean not like that you know I
just wanted to see how many subscribers
she had and there was like no premium
content so I was like how where are you
making she said she made 50k a month so
I'm like it's not true well no I was
thinking it could be like prostitution
oh that was my thought like over it's I
think I think it is prostitutions yes
well yeah but I was thinking like if
they don't make it through there maybe
they go through yeah well it's it's a
very sad thing because you could also
imagine someone being embarrassed about
that not admitting there not making any
money and then what they're saying to
make themselves sound impressive
convinces more young women to do the
same thing that they're doing so you
know maybe they're making fifty dollars
like again no amount makes that worth it
but that is um that is really sad well I
got good news though with AI technology
all of this industry will be wiped out
wiped out clean all these women there
will not be women who are making a
living doing this anymore it's going to
be a bunch of dudes and they're going to
be going to you know
porn.ai or whatever I don't even know
that exists and they're going to be like
render me a video of like two guys in a
check and then it's gonna render the
video and they're gonna upload it and
charge five bucks for it but then what's
gonna happen is every person in the
world will just buy a subscription to
the porn AI bot and just tell it
whatever they want yeah and so then
women will be like these women who are
doing it now are going to be like I
can't make any money doing it anymore
dude porn has already caused so many
problems for society AI porn is just
going to be unbearable dude people are
going to go insane you'll be able to
change it in real time you'll be
watching like
I'm sorry today
I have a question do you think with the
growing like rise of sexless men that
porn is actually like helpful to society
because they're not then aggressive
maybe that typically happens I think
like wasn't that a conspiracy theory and
also with with do you think it keeps
together sexless marriages
uh so if so I would say that if it's a
crutch to lean on it actually causes far
more problems than it solves uh I think
that like the Warped understanding of
sex that we have in the first place that
allows for for porn to be uh not only
legal but so prolific is the same
corrupt set of sexual morals that allows
for things like no fault divorce and for
these sexless marriages to happen so I
think it's all one uh part of the same
corrupt infrastructure and we just have
to do away with all of it you know you
know I think I think women care
substantially more about what other
women think of them oh yeah and so
that's a big component of all all of
this when it comes to marriages when it
comes to people who are upset there you
you and maybe it's just because of of
what I see in TVs and movie and what I
hear from other people which are who are
influenced by teams and movie but it
seems so often there's many stories of
women who are like in a relationship
with the husband and then they're
talking to their other woman friend and
they say here's the thing my husband and
they go oh no oh that's so bad and then
they're like oh no and now I feel bad
about it you're absolutely right like
I've talked to so many and that's why
like the Trad cons will come in and be
like oh just find the right girl she
won't do any like the divorce stuff they
won't be in a sexless marriage just find
the right girl but the thing is like
women are so easily influenced like I'll
have guys for the divorce documentary
they'll have a girl she had like all the
typical like checkpot like boxes checked
that you would want in a wife and then
like she gets in the wrong group of
friends and then she just divorces her
husband takes the kids takes half and
just ruins this man's life well divorce
is contagious right yeah we know that if
you have a friend who's divorced you're
you're more likely to get divorced I
would say that it's really important
like it in our modern time we have this
very like atomized vision of what family
should be you know you just have two
people living in a house together with
their children no extended family nearby
and you're also not part of a community
that has the same values as you I would
say uh if somebody wants to live a
traditional life it's not enough to find
one other traditional person right uh
you you probably want to be surrounded
by people in a community that is more
traditional where it would be an
absolute Scandal if you enter ended up
getting divorced well I just I think
that's going to be harder and harder
with media absolutely and so but the
thing is I just think things won't
really change until they change the laws
that's my personal opinion I think
there's truth and it's it's so difficult
50 50 custody would be something like
where and maybe like something to
protect men from not getting absolutely
wrecked with like child support spouses
well we should just get rid of no-fault
divorce agreed all right banished
birth control too this is what this is
this is what what feminists are arguing
we did a segment on no fault divorce and
then they started ragging on us and they
gave Sheamus's quote to Ian Ian it was
one of my best quotes ever they gave it
to even Ian Crossland even cross even
crossed even though I got a good quote
what they're arguing is that marriage is
now better because women and men can
both of them can just leave whenever
they want that's what makes them better
that's literally not marriage so my
point is okay fine here's here's what I
want to say to all of those feminists
whatever it is you have now let's keep
it exactly the way it is but we'll
create something called super marriage
and if after you're married you decide
to enter a super marriage now you can't
get divorced without a valid reason
problem solved yeah I mean look I agree
with you that we need to end no fault
divorce I said this this is one of the
things that Jezebel was so core uh
horrified by that they quoted it and
gave the quote to Ian Crossland but
people people talk about how many
marriages fail and if you know if we had
we removed no fault divorce so many
people be stuck in these marriages all
right well they don't consider is that
people are less cautious about who they
choose to marry because divorce is an
option and also because we live in a
culture where people do have sex before
they're married they end up being
blinded by the sex they don't evaluate
the person objectively they end up
become becoming bonded by all the
chemical reactions that happen in their
brain when they have sex with somebody
and so you end up making really bad
decisions people say well if we change
the cultural Paradigm what what about
all these people who made these bad
decisions there's going to be fewer of
them there will be fewer people making
those kinds of decisions
I I was going to answer your question um
about porn and if it's because I think
it is doing is and I'd love to talk more
about no-fault divorce too it burns my
mind almost every day
um that I think it is helping young
people get their aggression out and
maybe it's it's it's winding Tighter and
Tighter and Tighter until it explodes
but a lot of times young sexless men
they just get put into the military to
go kill and I I'm not seeing that now I
mean it's it's drastic in the other
direction you might argue that nobody or
hardly anybody wants to go fight so
maybe it's the completely depleted the
testosterone of the youth maybe we need
enforce the monogamy actually I have
another question so the more the more
women have been in charge of their own
mate selection the more Partners we've
had so is there something about women
that's actually not monogamous well no
because I think what you're touching I
mean those those things are correlated
right so
um that's correlated with the Advent of
reliable methods of artificial
contraceptive uh and even like even when
you haven't started before like the
birth rate started to decline before it
actually like because a lot of people
think it was the 60s but it's actually
been declining since the 1800s and in
1920 like we do see a dip in the birth
rate and like they they attribute that
to women like living in an apartment
outside like by herself or before she
would go straight from like her parents
house to her husband's house oh wow so
so it's interesting like when you think
about it like it did like women like
then began to have more Partners
sexually so it's like it seems like like
throughout history like they've just
been trying to like keep women from like
not to be so you're saying that
women should be allowed to own property
do I actually have never thought about
that question
um
so I like it I don't know I haven't
thought about it but I think what's been
pretty well understood by basically
every culture through all of history is
like men are gonna try to have sex right
men are going to try to persuade women
to have sex with them and so societies
have understood that we need to get
women to be really good at saying no to
this uh or else everyone's just going to
be having sex outside of marriage you're
gonna have a lot of illegitimate
children a lot of infanticide and
abortion which is what ended up
happening uh that's that's actually not
hyperbolic if you look at ancient Rome
the more sexually licentious people came
the more in fantasized there was I mean
it's a reality do you think I wanna oh
at that point do you think it would be
better for you or just for women in
general to have like three kids with
three different phenomenal dudes or
three kids with one guy I would say
three kids with one guy then I well I
guess I guess you have to if you think
about it from like a gene perspective
you probably get better like quality
jeans I'd imagine if you said they're
like hi but like for yeah but for a
society no like the one that's like
saying let me let me try different guys
three different guys because one of the
kids will succeed instead of being like
let's just have kids together and raise
them I'm not I'm just I'm playing
Devil's Advocate I'm like
yeah exactly that's
right I want to pull up the story from
the New York Post because I love this
making women look dumb is a new
disturbing podcast Trend and of course
I'd like to get my members here here's
uh here's a picture from the whatever
podcast and there's uh Mary Morgan from
uh pop culture crisis they're sitting
with the crew and then you've got uh
Destiny hanging out and uh you know why
I I take issue with this article
because if the whatever podcast has Mary
on the show and she is based and very
smart how are they making women look
dumb when they have women on who also
criticize other women and they criticize
each other like so so who are they
arguing is being made to look dumb are
they arguing the women he brings on are
making Mary look dumb making you Pearl
look dumb I would like to say I was very
offended when I saw this
because they didn't include my podcast
in it I don't know why my picture wasn't
there too
I just but but I actually I think you're
right though I think it's stupid like
women make themselves look stupid I
didn't do like I so I've
I've made fun of the whatever podcast
like I did a cartoon about it I
understand why it exists I do understand
it
yes yeah
yes yes that
glad you enjoyed that that was uh but I
I think that
my my view of it and maybe it's changed
a little bit uh recently actually is you
have this podcast and these young women
who kind of are very young and they just
regurgitate whatever the culture tells
them goes on the show then you have a
guy who's in his 30s who obviously knows
better because he's a guy in his 30s and
explains to them if they're wrong and
then it gets clipped and it goes viral
and it's like look at this uh dumb girl
one thing I was actually very
I'll say
um impressed by maybe something that
made me feel a little optimistic was
that when the roles were reversed and
Lila Rose was on that show and her is
like a good traditionalist woman she was
arguing with a man who was trying to
justify sleeping around pretty much
everyone in the comments was on her side
and every clip I saw of that video was
people praising her and so it does look
like even though the targets are usually
women with people on this who are
watching these podcasts are upset about
uh is the sexual Revolution and its
consequences and they don't like when
people kind of engage in these
rationalizations for this type of
behavior yeah yeah you know you know
what it is funny thing uh I will point
out though a trend on Instagram is for
women to make fake podcast Clips have
you noticed this no no on Instagram
female influencers will buy these
microphones and then they'll say
something
that's genius yeah yeah it'll be a clip
it'll just be them talking to one and
they'll say something like I think that
men should be good providers and too
many women you know insert opinion and
that's the end of the clip and it's got
a million views why do I even do my
whole hour-long podcast why do we do
this Tim let's just make Clips let's
make fake shorts for YouTube oh that's
crazy I think that the older women are
more delusional
well it's like I just think they're
Dumber on myself hold on when you say
older women do you mean older women or
like older women who are single because
that's also two separate categories
right
um
I mean I'd say the majority of people
that go on the shows are single okay so
but like I thought you're gonna say
you're dumb but I just wanna I just want
to point this out but I I would just
sorry no no finish your point I would
just say that I think that the older
women are more delusional on my show and
I think that's a lot of times like why
men date younger because they're like
thinking they'll be like better when
they're older but they're they're just
as delusional so look at this New York
Post says while only fans model
Nicolette Nicole admitted that her
appearance on the podcast was to bolster
her own following she told Vice the
clips were definitely chosen to create
controversy and make her look dumb and
shamer no no the only thing I want to
point out is calling somebody on only
fans a model
hahaha
no but you know what makes me mad okay
because what the girls will do is
they'll go on the show and then after
they'll play victim like oh boohoo poor
me they've done this on my show so many
times where like they'll come on and
then they'll they'll sometimes stay out
straight out missandrist
misandristic statements and then go back
later and say oh I'm a victim blah blah
blah when it's like if you say dumb
like there's so many women that go on
these shows and don't go viral and don't
say stupid and actually go viral
for the right reasons but if you go
viral for saying something stupid that's
that's your own fault well that's the
thing they say uh so the the article
it's being cited by the New York Post is
vice and their subhead is the whatever
podcast is baked you can stop falling
for it no it isn't they had Lila Rose
and Mary Morgan on that show where are
the clips making fun of them they're not
in fact the clips are praising them the
clip of Lila went viral because she was
like telling a guy off and then people
were like wow she's very smart even she
like she wasn't telling him off he was
trying to tell her often she was just
very calmly like stating her position
agitated was praising her yes what's
really happening comments was President
it's funny because I saw one of these
red pill channels posted to try to shame
her they're like oh this woman tries to
tell this Alpha what's what but all of
the comments on their Channel were like
no she's right like this guy's
completely wrong what Vice is actually
doing is saying stop making us look dumb
because we're dumb well they're no no
they're saying stop making the sexual
Revolution look bad because if this was
a bunch of left-wing men talking down to
women who were Trad wives and saying
you're an idiot who's missing out on
what you should be doing in life they
would say this podcast is great you
think do you think that it's women
should be like I think what happens a
lot of people get offended is the
thought that a woman is supposed to be
raising kids you're you are your job in
life is to be a wife and a mother and
like not everybody wants that I mean
maybe you might maybe people will argue
that every woman deep down does want
that the majority of women do want that
I would say I I think they surveyed
childless women or like it was like 80
or something 85 said they wanted kids I
can't remember the actual study I think
the issue is like they can't find the
right guy to have kids with or the guy
that they want
and like that and usually when I like I
talk to girls on the show they'll say
like I'm happy single or I'm happy not
having kids and I'll like if I ask
further questions and say like what
about if you found like the guy that
meets all your criteria and the majority
of the time they'll say yes yeah I I
remember I just want to mention this I
was at a bar with my my uncle my cousin
were visiting and so we were all at the
bar and her and I were the same age so
we must have been like 22 23 at the time
we're talking to this bartender who's
probably in her 40s and my cousin says
you know I'm like never gonna have kids
and the bartender's like how old are you
she's like I'm 22 and the bartender goes
shut up
shut up you're 22 you have no idea what
you want no 22 year olds should and they
I agree that they should but in this
culture they don't and if someone is
telling you like I know I don't want to
have kids here's the thing if they're
not saying I will sacrifice having a
family and sacrifice having children
because there is a broader Noble goal
which I wish to achieve then okay I
think that's a person who probably does
know what they want and can take you can
take seriously but if they're saying I
know in my early 20s I don't want to
have kids and it's for selfish reasons
okay this is just someone who's immature
that's not like a well thought out Life
Plan that's I want to do things that
make me feel good instead of thinking
about what I can contribute I've learned
pretty early on that to not use terms
say I'll never do something or I'll
always do something it's just it always
fails no it's just
remember remember that video of the of
the kids in like the 50s they're being
asked about war whatever and they sound
like adults I know because it used to be
a war it was right it used to be that
kids were surrounded by adults and
learned very quickly how to socially
interact what was and what wasn't now
kids do nothing for five years we put
them in front of iPads or computer
screens and they watch Elsa another
nonsense then they go to kindergarten
where they dance around with pride Flags
then they get institutionalized and
learn garbage nonsense for like they
don't learn real world things then
finally by the time they're 22 they get
out of college having been
institutionalized their whole lives and
they don't know how to operate in the
real world yeah it's because it's not a
biological problem I mean it might be an
endocrine system problem but I'm the
culture I look online and I'm like okay
there are so many hot girls there's so
many hot girls online I'll watch
whatever I watch all these and I'm like
these beautiful young women Prime
candidates for motherhood like and where
why are they not having kids what is
going on you know what the number one
like indicator I forgot what what the
stat is but it's basically like the
birth rate goes down when women go to
college so like women start having like
less children when they started going to
college and it's and and they all also
when mate selection was more in the
woman's hands basically what happened
when it became more in the woman's hands
yeah because because like in the 20s
that was when women started to get their
own apartment so like before they would
go straight from the dad to the husband
and like then women like started to go
and get like the Roaring 20s right they
started getting their own apartment and
like they then had more control of their
mate selection and like when women have
more control of their mate selection
they go for a smaller and smaller
percentage of guys where it's like you
know I mean why would they keep the bad
boy away when they say like get that guy
away from my daughter because they like
the dad knew he's not gonna stick around
but women it's like we're just so stupid
when it comes to mate selection just
because you work not you personally but
work with emotions instead of yeah
instead of logic
yeah and and it's also like I don't
think we have a good grasp of like our
league like I think women often sleep
out of their league well that that
that's that's the factually true though
yeah like all of the uh scientific
research and and uh dating data yeah
show that women always go for the most
attractive men but they tend to be able
to because men have a wider range of
willingness about like women have a very
tight range of their willingness to
sleep and men have a very wide range so
what happens is it's something like what
like the bottom six percent of guys are
just like left out of it and then it's
mostly the top 20 of guys who are
sleeping with all of the women yeah well
and and the other thing they they'll
always say oh well dating apps aren't
real life but that's the number one way
people are meeting under 30. that's true
dude those things are depression have
you ever used those things the dating
apps no not really yeah I started to do
it for market research because I was
building mines in the social app we're
like let's maybe do a Tinder thing and
then I got addicted to it I met a girl
on it and it was like just I'm like look
why I'm judging these people by the way
they look it's the most superficial crap
and I felt sick depressed afterwards
well I mean it's honest I think most
guys it starts with looks you know what
I mean but it's like the sound of their
voice and the way they smell is a big
dude it's just go on and swipe right on
every single one because there's like
the the I was I was reading uh
data on how men and women use these apps
differently women go on dating apps and
then swipe right on guys they find
attractive and then get messages from
every single guy and then guys go on
there and swipe on every single girl
hoping one of them measures with them
right well think about it like women
swipe right five percent of the time
guys just like there's a video where
guys
swiping everything it's like between 40
and 60 depends on the time of day if
it's after one a.m it's probably gonna
be like 70 or 80 because I'm in a
desperate mode I'm not anymore but at
the time I was that was uh yeah
because women like pick non-monogamy in
our 20s and then pick monogamy in our
30s when you think about it but that but
that's obvious you know why
like it's getting harder for the woman
as she gets older so now she's like I
need a guy who's not going to go
anywhere yeah but that but again like so
when you have a culture like ours where
the the sexual revolution has just
completely destroyed the relationship
between both sexes that seems to be what
tends to happen but like in most
traditional cultures that's not the case
right like people settle down early they
get married women are known for straying
less often than than men do and so this
is part of what I was emphasizing
earlier this is why and I believe Fulton
Sheen even said this like a society's
value can be measured by the value of
its women because the men are always
going to want to sleep around the
question is uh are women going to be the
gatekeeper and say well like no we're
we're not having sex unless we're
married unless you can provide a stable
uh home and family for myself and for
our children and you're actually going
to stick around
I guess there's a diminishing return to
raising Psychopaths like if you'd have a
lot of kids that were all horrible
humans that would be worse than having
very few kids that were phenomenal
humans but then there comes a point
where it's like population risk you
might lose the human population if you
don't have enough kids so it's better to
just churn them out but like I think
that in order like is it better or worse
in other societies where they didn't
have a sexual Revolution the thing is we
have well no Society has survived a
sexuality I think it's coming everywhere
I think like with social media like I
and I get messages from guys all over
the world saying okay like feminism is
coming and you have places that were
typically like more traditional like
India is a one percent divorce rate and
I get messages all the time like saying
that under 30 and I don't know the exact
stat but under 30 like the divorce rate
is rising because Western ideas are
going everywhere and in my opinion most
places I think like I think it's going I
don't want it to get bad like I don't
want it to get worse but if I had to
predict it I think like you will see
women getting more modern well you've
seen the psychological operations the
military's been doing they get like a 20
year old like e-girl and then they have
her make an account where she's talking
about how great it is to be in the army
or the Navy or whatever to get Sims to
join yeah oh my goodness yeah operations
with what Pearl's saying about how in
countries that were more traditional you
see an increase in these abnormal
lifestyle choices this is the one form
of colonization and imperialism that the
left is very very comfortable with
if we went into these countries and we
destroyed their temples or took their
gold the left would be very upset and
rightfully so but instead what we're
doing is exporting ideas that literally
destroy these people's families and it's
praised it's celebrated but I wonder if
you were able to pull because now we're
in the age of of revealment you know the
Revelation we're in we're in the the
apocalypse essentially we're seeing the
thoughts of people now that we didn't
used to see so yeah we're seeing the
misery of the unmarried but if we had
seen into the minds of people in 1938
would they be just as miserable or more
because they were getting beat by their
husbands like Sean Connery check this
analysis that men were all just beating
their wives yeah like oh that's a way of
a propaganda that they did in like the
40s I can't remember when they did it
there's this girl who like breaks it
down really well her name's Rachel
Wilson she wrote the book of cult
feminism but the propaganda like it's
mainly propaganda this idea that like
men were beating their wives left and
right like they it's a wave of
propaganda that was like between the 40s
and the 60s
yeah well you obviously have always had
men who were bad people there have been
horrible human beings throughout all of
history and yes the man is the head of
the household so he's an authority and
sometimes people abuse their Authority
that doesn't mean you do away with
authority right that doesn't mean
Authority is illegitimate and so yeah
there have always been animals who beat
their wives the idea that that is
inherent to or inherent to the family
structure into male headship in the home
is a leftist lie well complete nonsense
inherent only to marriages where you
can't escape if the woman's bound and no
one's going to take her word for it kind
of thing well but if you're in a
traditional way so so there's a couple
ways to approach this firstly if you're
in a traditional Community where people
are near their family and friends if you
married my sister and you're beating her
or you married my daughter and you're
beating her like people had larger your
families she had a lot of brothers she
had a dad she had other men who were
interested in protecting her like there
were very serious social incentives to
not be that kind of person if you added
in you to be that kind of person the
idea that men were going ah we're in the
patriarchy so I'm okay if my sister's
husband beats her or my my daughter's
husband beats her sorry
yeah it's it's complete nonsense that is
that has always been one of the most
universally detested behaviors by men
nothing makes men angrier uh than woman
beaters other than maybe uh sexual
abusers and people who fantasize about
stopping villains and protecting women
and children it's like every action
movie ever it's Spider-Man trying to
save Mary Jane and a School Bus full of
children and then there are bad guys who
do bad things and what feminists would
have you believe is that what man really
fantasize about is being that villain
who wants to hurt women it's nonsense
yeah it is completely I bet a lot of the
violence of the 1900s comes from like
post-war to guys coming back from the
war and being coming alcoholic and just
a mad aggression unfocused aggression
were you about to say something
but like the idea that feminists were
the ones who came around and told us
that woman beating as bad as the most
insane nonsense right well I I can't
remember who I was talking to but they
someone was talking about how there's
like a rape culture oh yeah yeah so I
worked with somebody uh and she asked me
how many of your friends are okay with
rape and I was like what do you mean and
she was like how many of the guy friends
you know are like cool with it and I was
like zero none what are you talking
about she was like come on really yeah
and then I was like what are you kidding
do you actually think that guys in this
world are all joking and laughing about
this stuff and then she said we live in
a rape culture that promotes it I said
what are you talking about Law and Order
SVU has been on for like 20 years and
the whole premise of the show is that
it's especially heinous and we're trying
desperately to stop it well and again
they've also expanded the dash of
definition of rape and sexual assault so
so it's like the like what is sex sexual
assault
like that that can include like a guy
grabbing a girl's butt at a bar is that
the same thing as like what you would
think yeah
it's a salt but it's not the same and
the other and that's still very wrong
and the other thing they don't talk
about is in Family Court family in court
is not based on evidence it is not it is
not innocent until proven guilty it is
based on a balance of probabilities and
it's again it's I think it's a different
state by state here but I know that a
lot of us like um family courts it's the
same in the UK this is how they do it so
it's basically it's more likely you did
it than you didn't but it's not based on
evidence right so so a lot so a lot of
times what will happen and I interview
these guys is like their their entire
reputation is ruined in these
communities so one these women and the
crazy thing is oh my gosh these guys um
they'll be married right and the woman
will go to the women's shelters and at
the women's shelters like it's basically
a business so they'll tell the women
what to say based on your background so
you know you're Irish so they might say
okay he's a drunken Irish or some
something like that and the women and
with one phone call can get a
restraining order around the guy and
typically he can't even like fight like
and with that one phone call he can be
kicked out of the house he pays for he's
still paying for a mortgage on it and
she can also take the children so with
one phone call she can do that and it
takes like it can take some of the guys
that took them up for to a year to even
go to court about this and now and a
year without your children and now in
the UK the other thing is they are paid
to they get a free lawyer if they accuse
a guy of sexual assault grape or abuse
in court so what will happen is all
these guys will be known as an abuser a
sexual assault like great I don't know I
don't know you can say on here rapists
in these communities and it's like the
women have all the power they can do
this with one phone call and it's not
based off of evidence have you guys
heard about what's going on with Bam
Margera no a little bit Yeah so
apparently the story is he hasn't seen
his kid in months and his argument and
his lawyers argue that it's arbitrary
that he's being denied access to his son
under some argument about the safety of
the child but he's he's he was he's
arguing like there's no risk of child at
all this is this is ridiculous she's
just keeping from my kid so he's having
a breakdown he's getting depressed he
says he cries every day and so he calls
his family and says you're keeping me
from my son and then apparently he said
this is what they reported that he said
he would smoke crack till he died if he
didn't get to see his kid so they sent
the cops after him the cops 51.50 to him
meaning they took him to him they
involuntarily institutionalized him
because like dude if you deprive a man
of his child then he becomes extremely
depressed and says let give me back my
son like they make movies about this
with Harrison Ford you know what I mean
like instead they're like lock him up I
I spoke to a guy for the documentary the
other day the wife is um treating the
kid as gender binary or gender neutral
there's nothing he can do about it yeah
she's abusing what yeah that situation
um his name's Harrison the daily wire
covered at Harrison did wait did you
donate to his cause is this in Canada I
actually think he he told me you did I
don't did I Harrison T something yeah I
probably did yeah yeah but like no it
was in California okay okay I was a
GoFundMe did I give there's a guy yeah
James I think I think he told me you did
not younger tell us more no but
basically like his um his
ex-girlfriend was like raising the kid
as like non-binary and like he's just
spent all this money trying he still
doesn't have primary custody even though
she's literally and there's nothing he
can do about it this is not Jessica yeah
guys you should you guys should donate
to this in the chat because he's
actually really nice he's super nice and
you can oh yeah yeah you can tell she
like loves his son I did so this is a a
Gibson go help a single father fight for
a son I gave him ten thousand dollars
and this is like this is what a father's
supposed to do right he's trying to
fight for his child right but it's so
interesting because a lot of the Trad
cons will be like oh well why don't men
just like fight for their kids and it's
like well if you saw what they have to
go through like a lot of guys go
bankrupt because again with that one
phone call she he's paying for a
mortgage that he's not even living in
like because the the house is still in
his name so he's paying a mortgage on a
house that is like he's not not he's
kicked out of because of the restraining
order then before this is before court
even happens he can be on child support
and the entire Community thinks he's an
abuser and a lot of these guys have lost
their his jobs their their jobs because
like I mean if you're all your friends
eat sometimes your family thinks you're
an abuser right you're gonna go kind of
crazy yeah and so like a lot of times
these guys now they're unemployed now
they're in a ton of debt and there's
nothing they can do and this is when a
lot of guys zero out and they kill
themselves it's very sad and I think um
I think that is one explanation like a
lot of people they they fight until they
can't anymore like as a traditionalist
conservative I don't know that I've ever
heard anyone say that about someone who
like literally couldn't fight anymore
they did that's like a callous approach
to it well no because what they'll do is
they'll look at the stat that says like
men like the men that fight for their
kids get custody but they don't like and
so they'll say well why don't people
just fight for their kids and it's like
okay yeah but the average guy doesn't
have a hundred thousand dollars to spend
to get custody of his children
interesting so yeah and the lawyers will
tell them this like because it's kind of
if you're a lawyer yeah yeah because
it's it's a tough like it's tough for
guys to win unless the mother is like
there's something wrong with her so the
cases that do go to court like typically
there's something wrong with a woman
even then there was a case with that
that little boy that was eventually
killed by his mother they gave her
custody because she's the mother okay
right I don't know that was in the
United States and it was clear that she
was addicted to meth Etc and all these
things and they still gave her custody
because again like you said it's just
based on probabilities and those
probabilities in this case it was an
unusual case and like I think literally
the day or a day after they gave it back
to her she she had killed the boy so
that I I spoke there's one guy in the
documentary in the UK very similar case
I've heard of many cases yeah there's a
very similar case in the UK and this guy
um he his um friends like this was the
kid who dies like like best friend and
the government just took the kid they
didn't even give it back to the dad the
government just took the kid we're gonna
go to super chats but uh I will add I I
actually forgot that I I donated to that
guy but uh I saw his story and and I was
I was moved by it and I also you know
want to want to help so I donated ten
thousand dollars uh
I've also donated ten thousand dollars
to uh an activist to push back on child
sex change laws and to help fight
against it I'm saying this now because I
guess my question for everybody is I
didn't mention that I did this and I
don't know if I should or shouldn't you
know what I mean like dude don't mention
that stuff man you're The Dark Knight
Rises the question like with the gift
sign to go for that guy it's like
publicly you can see my name but nobody
wrote about it nobody said anything
about it with Daniel Penny it was big
news and everybody was putting my name
on top and that one I said I did but for
this uh this activist fighting against
the the child sex change stuff and for
this guy fighting for his kid I just
didn't say anything about it I just like
did it and but I'm wondering if people
think that it would be good if I did I
like I I don't want it to be like ah
look look at me look how great I am but
maybe it might be like hey look there's
a big impact happening so I'm curious
it's weird to be like look how much I
donated I get that but it's good to
spread awareness for the cause itself so
sometimes it's worth you know expressing
it yeah no I think it's like if you do
it like I think it inspires other people
to do it too I think it's say something
when you do when I do I think yeah yeah
I think people know like you're a nice
guy I don't think you're trying to like
flash your money in people's you know
right well I also think too it's like
just understand we run a successful
company here and I think that the money
we make should go towards things that
are good and we put our money where our
mouth is so yeah like donating to this
guy to fight for his kid I think it's
exactly what people ex people would
would want their money to be doing yeah
and a lot of the money that we get like
advertising and stuff like that and a
portion of it is memberships obviously a
lot of it's going for infrastructure and
things like that but I'm just like I
don't know I kind of feel like that's
what we should be doing with it yeah you
know I don't know and he's so like I
could just tell how bad like he spent so
much money trying to get his kid and I
could just tell like how happy he was to
finally have like I think he has 50 50
custody now yeah yeah yeah but he yeah
like um and I I could just see how like
much so people should donate because
he's actually he's really nice he's
going to be in the documentary so let's
talk about some super chats here so
smash that like button subscribe to the
channel and head over to timcast.com
because the members only uncensored show
will get a bit more spicy and not so
family friendly because then we're gonna
talk about more family issues and uh
again timcast.com click join us it'll be
up at about 10 pm and we'll be live then
you can even call in and ask questions
all right belly flop says Hear Me Out
presidents don't have term limits but
every year or two they can be voted out
keep good ones in as long as possible
remove the bad ones ASAP current
two-term system is anti-matter
interesting I see when it comes to this
this question of of term limits and also
how we modify the presidency I'm not
sold on this idea but one interesting
idea I have heard is one six-year term
so they don't have to worry about
re-election they also don't have as much
time in office but they're also not
spending time campaigning right I think
that's pretty interesting and then
sometimes like their policies will
actually take still be able to see some
of the early effects of those policies
opposed to like you'll see in the
beginning of the next person that then
takes over if they're if they get voted
out for other things they're not related
at all I agree with that it's a good
idea yeah all right let's read this and
not your buddy guy says Idris Elba
couldn't play James Bond he isn't Suave
enough like Jason Statham he could play
generic Action Hero now Henry Cavill
could play James Bond you are correct
sir I I completely agree with what
you're saying and I see it I was saying
earlier like I didn't care if it just
double play James Bond a lot of people
are concerned about race swapping The
Little Mermaid flopped and I think a
component of white flopped is the the
race swap because people aren't going to
feel the Nostalgia seeing a character
they don't recognize whereas with James
Bond they change the actor all the time
however you make a really good point
Idris Elba is I think a fantastic actor
and a great action star and has done
incredible roles but he doesn't have
that smarmy bit that James Bond does
like you know James Bond call it sweet
smug yeah yeah he's got that smugness to
him like shaken monster I'm so special I
want my drink made just for me as a as a
part of a minority group uh gingers
I was very sad that they took out the
red hair because that's always what I
was for Halloween as a child I know I
know it's weird there is a weird redhead
eraser thing all my redhead friends have
been telling me about that like it's
always a redhead character who gets
recast and now all right hillbillary not
good I know I was just gonna say ginger
representation bring it back hillbillary
Clinton says I'd like to think the B are
tired of us and are ready to end it all
and flood the Earth again is that what
the beaver split the earth I love the
implication just again no no no you
understand the Beavers are the how and
not the why ah of course of course yeah
yeah so so when God flooded the Earth
you have to understand how the flood
happened
the Beavers do it the the see we're not
the Earth is not like the world is on
the back of a turtle
it's a gigantic Valley surrounded by Big
Beaver Dams beavers it's true that's
right
a bunch of beaver dams and they could
just choose to uh the great beavers that
build a firmament they become too
displeased Frozen sticks oh man
the quartering says I'm just here to
remind people about coffee brand coffee
Father's Day gift boxes are running out
and learn how to finally find a wife
from Pearl let's talk about the
quartering for a minute coffee brand is
awesome quartering is awesome coffee
coffee brand coffee are you are you guys
your fans oh yeah I'm a big fan of
Jeremy yeah I mean and I'm saying coffee
brand coffee as many times as possible
because he paid for it do you know do
you guys get along no he's always
tweeting at me oh you guys should do a
show or something he's hilarious yeah I
mean he's about as based like uh
straight forward as you can get yeah
yeah
yeah I mean I would if he was nicer to
me on Twitter he's just he's quite rude
yeah that's the problem with text is
there's no context yeah and tone is lost
yeah well I mean he's insulted my looks
a couple times that's pretty rude well
that's not nice yeah did you insult him
no no that never instead of him then you
should tell everyone to buy Casper
we'll uh we'll buy we'll buy Casper ads
on your channel
be nice on Twitter man the world's your
oyster Montana Gibson says Tim please
get this out I work for Adam's beverage
who delivers BL products for Al and NC
is that Bud Light they want me to finish
my conscious inclusion training and I'm
not going to do it would love some
advice on what to do if they fire me I
would I if I were you I would um
write down take notes of everything
whatever the conscious inclusion
training is and then bring it to a
lawyer it's often what you'll find with
these inclusivity trainings is they're
overtly racist they'll say like white
people do this thing and white people
think this and not only that many of
these trainings will show stereotypes of
Mexicans Asians and black people and
their intention is to be like don't
stereotype them some people think this
about Mexicans and then doing that is
racist because like you could then go to
the EOC and say you know no one was
saying anything about this particular
racial group and these things until they
brought everyone into a room made him
sit down and watch a video explaining to
them how to make fun of people based on
race and I think that alone is violating
like businesses should not be able to go
to you and be like here's what some
people think about this race but they've
done that so it really just depends on
what that training has and you know talk
to a lawyer
what do we got here from Raymond g
Stanley Jr he says question Tim as we
move as we move to forward the line
we're starting to Fight Fire with Fire
the cult would attack popo department
online would it be wrong for us through
the same for the reading PD you mean
like activist stuff like criticizing
them and sending emails and everything
like you should definitely do uh phone
calls like the you guys hear about the
Christian guy who got arrested for
preaching I don't know uh was this in
Canada
I've heard of it happening in Canada
because in Pennsylvania and there's a
pride rally it's been about time and a
couple of guys were holding up one guy
was holding up a sign that had like is
that God
um what did it say I mean you guys might
know he was about to say something like
God is not the one who spreads confusion
or something like that maybe you know
the quote is that uh I didn't see I mean
I I didn't you got arrested for
preaching the cop told them stop saying
this or else and he was like it's a
public sidewalk and I can say these
things and the cop arrested him
yep so definitely I think you should
criticize the writing uh is it writing
or reading I don't know Damon Atkins is
the guy that got arrested is that his
name yeah yep I think it's crazy I'm
like if you were a classical liberal
this should be like alarm bells in your
head the guy was standing on a public
sidewalk and he yelled God is not and
they grabbed him and arrested him right
you're allowed to stand on the street
corner with a sign and protest dude the
Christian right literally predicted
everything that's happening right now or
did everything manifested no I we didn't
manifest it bro uh this is like what's
happening right here is actually a
political cartoon like somebody could
have made this as a political cartoon 10
years ago where it's two panels and
there's a gay pride parade and a
Christian protesting it then the police
come and like arrest the Christian and
thoughts was going to happen yeah I've
been saying this for years the Christian
rights been saying it for like 30 years
the cop probably arrested him because
he's thinking there's two things one the
cop is ideologically captured and agrees
with them maybe there's also the
possibility he's sitting there thinking
if this guy keeps yelling they are gonna
Riot they're gonna smash windows I
better arrest him first yeah disturbing
yeah disturbing the piece protecting
this is somewhere in Canada no pets no
this is in Pennsylvania I was asking if
it's in Canada because that's it's like
I can't believe it no I just know Canada
is far worse and they're either like
hate speech laws do prohibit reading
certain parts of scripture so
all right where are we at Let's uh grab
some more Super chats Sean at the clue
says the bow tie was a mind control
device the bow tie was actually Tucker
the last doesn't want you to know this
but look at my bow tie
you are feeling very sleepy actually
actually
what do we got run DC Jesus Elon just
retweeted Tucker's episode one pour in
the views
wow and he got like when we pulled it up
within two hours he had nine million
views on it let's see where he's at now
yo he's gonna be able to sell some hot
advertisements on that yeah like imagine
what it's going to be like episode two
he's gonna he's gonna open up the show
and be like hello America and then it's
gonna immediately cut to everybody
thanks for checking out Tucker Carlson's
new Twitter episode my pillow is the
greatest pillow
it is current view is 20.8 million 24 8
million dude that's gonna start costing
like a Super Bowl ad at least wow if not
twice as much 28 million no it's good
it's the first one so it's probably
gonna go down true but I imagine it'll
be like six seven million per episode
every night and Elon got 7.7 of that
million for him according to these
elon's retweet got 7.7 million so that's
28 million yeah of his 28.5
total
no no August 20 I think seven million of
them come from Elon do you know how that
tracks the original video has 20 million
elon's retweet has 7 million does that
mean that the original I think they're
both separate I think they're both
separate tweets this might get my dad on
Twitter he's a big Tucker Carlson fan
yeah Tucker that's why elon's retweeting
because he knows a lot of people are
going to sign up now to watch Tucker's
show yeah Tucker's got good lighting you
know what's actually really funny my dad
said something similar to me recently
he's like well no the Twitter is a more
free speech I was like is it because of
Tucker Tucker if you're listening the
right side of your video is a little
dark so you could brighten up your left
cheek a little bit I do looks awesome
dude I do think I I saw someone tweet
like excellent production quality and
I'm like is that a dig because the
production quality was like C plus at
best I'm not trying to rag on Tucker's
fantastic I'm just saying like yo bro I
will I will for free send someone out
and help him set everything up to like
get get a pot like high quality audio
whatever he needs I mean he certainly
has the means to to hire whoever and I'm
sure there's more than enough
connections his show should be way
higher how it's it's kind of funny when
I started to get good at like making
content and whatever it baffled me how
many shows that are so big have such low
production quality where I'm like you
guys are so big how on Earth do you have
this low of production I mean to be fair
like to a degree we do too really you
got your mics are nice I was talking
about sure yeah yeah but the cast is
horrible
sm7b the the new studio that we're
building we're getting a pro company to
do like a super high-end crazy yeah it's
gonna be these lights could be better
he's not gonna let me know they wash a
little bit so you get kind of like the
same color the whole brightness I was I
was looking at your mics I was like I
want those you got it these are these
are industry standard mics they're
actually not that expensive
like around 300 which is like a lot of
money but for an in like industry um
standard like cameras are thousands of
dollars like I'd like to just be 300
we're the one under it but when I bought
them we weren't like we were a lot
smaller but it's like you want to
replace all of them yeah I don't know
this is a write-off the best audio is so
key and internet videos oh yeah let's uh
let's read some more P gar says ask
Sheamus if is a marriage outside of the
church an actual marriage uh there's
such thing as natural marriage yeah
natural marriage yeah
no like human beings got married before
Christ elevated it to the level of a
sacrament
so just some public ex
explanation basically a public
explanation of your of your mixing yeah
souls or something yeah yeah I mean I I
um but it's about the public it's not
knowledgeable isn't it yeah I guess like
the mixing of the souls that's another
question and that I would have to like
refresh myself more on like natural
verse um
versus uh sacramental marriage uh I know
some of the differences but I probably
could not get into all of them
competently right now but yeah people I
mean this is the thing the church uh
like marriage obviously existed before
the church uh existed no no Catholic
denies that no Christian denies that
there is such a thing as natural
marriage
well all right
what do we got here honest a-hole says
woman tells truth news at 11. and then
laughing emojis
yup
Jason Hutchinson said cheat codes and
games caused this if you're successful
in life you must have cheated I think
that's Marxism
yeah it sounds like yeah it sounds
pretty much the only way anyone can
succeed is if they stole it from someone
else
I made I made a birdhouse where'd you
get the wood from from my yard where my
tree is your yard
there's no answer you can give to them
it's always stolen everything is stolen
dang Lin Wang says I can't wait for
Sheamus's potato coffee blend ah is that
what we're doing we're gonna do we're
gonna do a certain type but then it
didn't taste very good honestly you want
to try we could do a sweet like sweet
potato marshmallow so it's like cinnamon
nutmeg marshmallow flavored coffee and
so it's not really potato but like you
know I'm surprised you guys don't have
the guests like try the coffee oh that'd
be a good idea well you could if you
want to yeah no I was thinking I was
like I wonder if it's anything but like
do people want to drink coffee late at
night oh it's so good addicts will what
do you mean yeah there's a decaf blend
right because I was thinking you can put
you could make like um even if you just
had them tested you can make like a
compilation for a commercial of everyone
trying the coffee sleepy Joe and unwell
there are decaf ones I'm full of them
but then what happens is when we have a
lefty on to debate he takes a second
you guys you guys get such a big guess
it's like you might as well have them do
marketing for it I'm sure oh yeah he's
in the green room we should have we
should have like a butler and a tuxedo
who stands there next to every single
person who's on the show holding a
sausage Brew Coffee on it yeah you know
we'll do we'll just do like video
appearance things like you agree to
appear on the show and let us use the
footage and then we'll we'll put the bag
behind them and say take a sip what do
you think and they're like this is
actually really good and then we'll have
an ad of like like you're saying like
we'll have Kanye West being like this is
good coffee they won't even realize
we're filming commercial for and even if
they don't like it you could like work
with them to make like a new one I like
well some people I'd imagine don't like
coffee right yeah but like No One's
Gonna be rude they're not going to beg
oh yeah it's pretty good
you're like you know what's that's all
right I would I would have I would
actually only use those it's like oh
it's it's okay I guess that's funny back
to back to back a bunch of those
it's actually insanely good Appalachian
nights I I'm not even kidding normally
what I do is I have a cup of coffee in
the morning and I'll drink it slowly
over the course of like an hour and a
half two hours yeah this one is so good
I just end up I wish I could try it you
know what I mean we can make it I don't
know okay
yeah you are allowed to have coffee yes
all right Sparky says Sheamus what if
the girl slept with Bill Lundberg from
the movie Office Space I don't even I
don't remember that character from
Office Space he's the boss oh my gosh
that's right that'd be that'd be great
actually that wouldn't be great what are
they asking what if the girls oh is he
saying like if you were here
I just got I just got that that's the
whole plot of oh my gosh yeah I saw that
movie kind of recently too and then it
turns out I was a different guy I
haven't been drinking my cast Brew so I
slept with Lumberg like would you flip
your lid that's hilarious that's
hilarious classic man
yeah I just saw office space for the
first time a few months ago I might
judge one of his best he's brilliant ah
that movie is so good calendar game says
this has been reflect refreshingly
different kind of episode it's like
whatever podcast except also the
opposite but you're just talking about
sex to cover for the aliens Tim has
antennae under the beanie that's
actually well I won't say anything about
under the beanie it's like like Piccolo
from Dragon Ball Z I love talking about
relationships I'm glad that that's your
specialty because Mass one of the most
important topics of our time NY bsfp
says AI porn is the answer to everything
else you're complaining about it's going
to put only fans out of business for all
of these naive girls that's the answer
to what we're complaining about it's not
the answer but it will abandon that
problems yeah right dude it's gonna be
it's gonna be nuts like dudes are going
to put on the VR headset and be like uh
Wonder Woman and uh uh Sansa Stark and
like uh a dog and then it's like the AI
is gonna make the weirdest crazy
nonsense and a carrot comes in but then
like there's a rabbit riding the carrot
and this is like basically to say this
will solve our problems that's like
saying like once the most insanely
customizable version of the lotus plant
is introduced to everyone and they start
munching on that all the time
everything's you know it's gonna be
great yeah Lotus that gets you high um
that's from uh The Odyssey
oh Homer's The Odyssey yeah yeah the the
you know they would eat the Lotus and
then it would kind of uh it would
aphrodisiac no no it it sort of like
made them kind of zombie-like uh yeah
like they they they they slept and
didn't care about things uh and they
made you like uh complacent to the world
yeah exactly exactly we're talking about
marijuana
um I could have been a metaphor for a
lot of things but uh I think porn
definitely fits into that water lily
that's the nilumbo nusafera
Aubry Lovett says no one seems to be
addressing how porn addiction in very
young men can often be the precipitating
event in their sexlessness later on yeah
I didn't see porn 2019 that's so I can't
really speak on it one of the things we
talk about is that virginity is rising
among men under 30. and it could be
because of porn addiction that they've
become like they've watched this weird
crazy garbage on the internet you know
because I love watching porn as a
scientist like I like seeing Oh that's
the position yeah that's the spot I get
that but as a kid I would have messed me
up I yeah I think it's more because that
like
um the most of men are invisible to
women I would say that's more why
there's virginity rising in my opinion
it's because they don't lift they gotta
start lifting I mean no part I mean
partially you're right but it's like 80
of men women find ugly not okay not
decent below average yeah no they find
them as ugly was ugly the term I thought
it was below 80 of them I thought it was
unattractive but that's because it's
like women like guys who are attractive
on the inside and I'm not actually
kidding like they they want guys who are
charismatic confident strong capable for
a guy he wants a symmetrical human body
that looks like and can produce children
and for women they want a guy who can
beat a bear in a boxing match you know
buy a company and then right hire well
it's like have you ever seen have you
ever seen the science of sex
quite a bit they they have uh a bunch of
women sit down at computers and they
show them pictures of men and they say
rate these men on a scale of one to ten
then they do right then they go out into
the street with all these pictures and
there's a guy who's like a tall chiseled
guy with like a you know strong John you
know wavy hair and a beard and he was
rated a nine by all the women like a 9.6
and so they go out into the street and
ask random women how would you rate this
guy and it's almost the exact same they
say oh he's a nine oh he's an eight oh
he's a ten but basically it averages out
to the same score they got in the lab
then they add to the photos a by a bio
where they show this guy who was who was
a nine they write down his age his date
of birth where he lives and they put his
occupation as theater manager the women
then read him as a seven they took a guy
who got rated a four who is short fat
and ugly but he's a software engineer
who makes 500 000 and the women rated
him a seven wow so like from four to
seven from nine to seven if you had a
bad job so like and that was the point
they're making that women care about
what a guy does not just what he looks
like because men are shallow yeah and
they care about status too status is a
huge part of it no I think that's like
there's definitely things you can do to
improve but I I just think like it's
like the women that 70 of us are
overweight one out of four of us has an
STD one out of three of us have had an
abortion average body count is between
five and eight eighty percent of men is
unattractive
you know what I mean so it's like what
like it's kind of like better like the
audacity I just saw a stat that the
average woman is 170 pounds 70 pounds
yeah what yeah the average one is 170.
like to think about think about you can
become a one percent man right top one
percent in like any category and you
still yeah and you still you still can't
expect a virgin yeah
but you can't like only five percent of
women are virgins yeah yeah like you
can't like you can become the upper like
Pinnacle of man and if you say like oh I
want a virgin it's like unlikely you'll
get one yeah true
then you'd think the math worked out
were top one percenters saying he's
gonna have five wives
for every one top one percent man
there's did you ever do multiple lives
no he's Catholic yeah
yeah all right here's one for Sheamus
Dark Horse 99 says Sheamus I want you to
know that you've convinced this atheist
to attend church with my wife and son
you keep doing you Tim the PA town is
pronounced like the color red Redding
reading yeah there you go God bless you
man thank you I'll be praying for you
please pray for me and if you're having
like if you're going to church thinking
this is great but I'm having trouble
believing I am an atheist just tell God
that ask him please
help me believe you got to go on the
whatever podcast you think so absolutely
yeah why don't you all go on yeah oh my
gosh just a group of us in a row on
[Applause]
has a substantially stronger opinions on
marriage family dating and all that
stuff
I think you definitely have to do you
think so I mean aside from Mary you know
have there been very many like are there
a lot of well actually no there's a lot
of Christian conservatives oh yeah come
on come on in London yeah yeah you guys
bring me out I'll get you I'll get you
yeah I'll get you a panel of women oh my
goodness yeah let's figure something out
I'm imagining what would actually be a
very funny Freedom tune skit where it's
like you're just you have like a
chalkboard and you're breaking down
things and like teaching I'm like I have
my glasses I'm like nothing we've done
we've done shows with the Whiteboard
yeah if you got if you got something to
say I'll give you a wipe oh that sounds
awesome
happily what would you if you had a
whiteboard presentation for 10 minutes
what would you make it on you want me to
spoil it right now
title of it I love it title it love Dr
Sheamus like obviously don't give us all
the goods but you know it's a title
[Music]
um I almost don't want to spoil it the
women would probably be something uh
bombastic you know like the sexual
Revolution and its consequences uh you
know okay too I'll get you a panel all
right fans girls we're gonna go to the
uncensored members only show called the
sexual Revolution and its consequences
coming up in just a few minutes
head over to timcast.com click join us
become a member because the uncensored
members only show we're gonna talk more
about family dating and stuff but now it
will be uncensored and not for the kids
to hear so uh you've been warned don't
bring your kids around so smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the share with your friends you
can follow the show at timcastirl you
can follow me personally at timcast
Pearl do you want to shout anything out
oh follow my YouTube channel just pearly
things
um also follow my Twitter pearly things
with a z and and guys I'm back on Tick
Tock I've been banned five times right
now uh your band just make another
account that's what I do and just pearly
thinks they gave me my original handle
back so just really think so really they
gave you your account your handle back
yeah like well it's been so long my
first band was like a year ago so I
think they realized yeah ours was too
yeah so maybe maybe your real your hands
no one took it yeah yeah my name's
Seamus Coughlin uh I have a YouTube
channel called Freedom Tunes where we
make animated cartoons we released a
video today that I think you guys are
gonna love we're also releasing one on
Thursday about these race swapped
reboots and modern reboots in general
that I think you guys are really gonna
like it's pretty spicy it's pretty fun
go over there check that out I also have
a podcast on Rumble called shamer had a
conversation with the one and only
wonderful Jimmy Aiken it was fantastic
we talked about UFOs the JFK
assassination other conspiracy theories
the man is an absolute encyclopedia
finally go to freedomtunes.com com help
support my work by becoming a member and
you'll get an extra cartoon each week
and that's Freedom Tunes with t-o-o-n-s
that's right but I bought both domains
more I couldn't get people to spell it
right intelligent you have high
intelligence thank you I appreciate it
uh Pearl also your Twitter you mentioned
is pearly things with a Z yeah uh and
you have a doc a divorce documentary
that's coming out yeah it's uh probably
fall like uh it's gonna come out when I
finish it do you have a working title or
anything or anything you want to talk
about this early on
um I mean I've interviewed like
basically dads that have been wrecked in
divorced it's going to have lawyers in
it judges in it like basically all the
people that are involved in the divorce
court system in the UK
um
and yeah I don't have a name for it yet
I don't know I let me know chat help me
think of one yeah yeah oh and uh I think
that's everything I'm gonna if you're
interested I'll get you some coffee for
the after show if you want to get a
little snippet yeah
we have a full pot downstairs or
something I probably could figure it out
yeah or I'll make a few glasses I don't
know if we just have that the cake up
the little pod thing yeah and uh we have
Mr Duprey on my right uh yes I am
surge.com off Twitter right now because
I just want to take a break and I feel
like it's good to do that because I
remember it's not real life but uh yeah
you can follow me anyways at sears.com
and uh yeah I'm excited to do this after
show so we have to hold our words we
will see you all over at timcast.com in
a few minutes thanks for hanging out